Okay.
Experience
fresh off of Ari.
She fears comedy central show.
This is not happening.
It's Ms Pat again.
Welcome back.
Thank you for having me.
Thanks for coming back again.
And uh,
I'm sorry to hear that a bunch of people were fucking with you online the last
time that you were on here.
A bunch of people have contacted you.
You made the cru crucial mistake of paying attention.
Now you can't pay attention.
Well,
you know,
I used to fight back in the day,
so if you say something about me,
I'm like,
well,
meet me at the gay coffee shop so I can whoop you away.
It's the gay coffee shop.
What's the gay coffee shop?
He's style books.
Why Starbucks?
The gay coffee shop.
You allow the white dude's got on dockers and shit.
There's a gay full,
I don't date guys in dockers.
Do you?
Why don't they guys?
But if I did,
I probably wouldn't have a problem with dockers.
Well,
I'm used to jeans,
baggy jeans.
I'm black.
Okay,
okay.
What were dockers exactly like a type of pants?
Yeah,
I was thinking of what they keep.
No,
I think it was like,
yeah,
they keep the big wallet in their back pocket.
Okay.
And that's not good.
I don't,
I don't know.
I mean,
I'm just saying,
I don't think those types of guys,
do you date types of dudes who like have their pants sagging?
Nah,
I'm been married for 23 years.
No,
but I mean if you did,
no,
no.
You wouldn't do that.
Does that gay too?
Yeah.
There's gay too.
And raggedy looking and very inappropriate.
I mean it's something breakout you can't ruin.
Right,
exactly.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a confusing thing to me that that pants sagging thing has lasted so long.
I'm so confused.
What's confusing to me is that the young girls think it's cute.
Do they think it's cute?
Yes.
You know,
my niece lived with me and she loved them.
They got a hell of they pants sagging real the father down the cuter.
They look really?
Yes.
They get excited by that.
My knees do with me.
That represents,
you don't have a job and you stupid and you look crazy and use an ass hole.
I got a son and he's 28 and I was like,
don't fucking let your pants Sag Sun.
You know you can,
you can barely get by now.
Pull your fucking pants up.
But he's not bad with it.
He's not bad when it's like meet him.
Well he's kind of fat so he ain't got no A's.
So his pants just kind of sag on the old.
He ain't trying to be cool.
That's how Joey Diaz is.
Joey does.
Parents are always falling down so much.
So at one point in time you started wearing suspenders.
Yeah.
So sometimes I think my son
Joey,
I didn't say that shit.
He did.
He was wearing fucking suspenders
done with his fucking pants falling out.
Bullshit you wearing.
But he didn't last.
It didn't last with suspenders.
Exactly.
It didn't want to accept the fact that he was a dude that wore suspenders.
You know,
this is a very particular type of dude that wears suspenders.
Orgasm Golf.
Who Golf.
Yes.
You got a bunch of categories.
Gay,
gay coffee shop is cause there's white dudes and dockers old guys who golf.
That's who wear suspenders.
Yes.
Unemployed black means make that the best sex and the,
yeah.
You said they have the most delicious thick.
I didn't say that's what you said.
Delicious.
It is what you said.
It's exactly what you said.
There's a difference between when a person is employed and unemployed,
how good this stakes is.
Really.
I think so.
I really do.
I think a person who has a nine to five don't have time to really throw you
against the wall at night because he got to go to work in the morning versus a
dude who don't do shit during the day.
Who can watch Jerry Springer with you and y'all can just practice on getting
better and better and badder.
So due to work too much.
Don't have the energy to fuck correctly.
I think so.
Don't you think so about a woman who,
fuck,
a lot don't.
But yeah,
I would imagine that the women that work all day or exhausted,
but I think anybody who works all day is physically.
That's why I say unemployed Dick is the best.
Dick.
You got a point.
I know what I'm talking about because I've had both.
I Bet I've had both.
It does make sense.
Well,
you can only put so much time into one thing,
you know,
like without,
if you want to have another side thing that you do,
I mean,
that's what sex really is.
If you really stop to look at it.
I mean,
it's something else.
It's an activity,
right?
You can't really get good at that activity that makes you working 12 hours a day
and that thing,
right?
Like it's like being a comedian with a job.
You Never gonna succeed until you quit your jobs.
True.
Yeah.
Like everything else.
Fighters have that same issue.
Um,
athletes of all sports,
you know,
if you're trying to work a day job and then do something else at night,
it's much more difficult to do.
It is.
You don't have all of the energy that you really need to put into it,
into a slinging that good day needed to take those long nap.
Eat at a leisurely pace.
Yes.
Blacks.
And then think about how are you going to slate it?
Yeah.
I don't have a dick.
I'm just saying from experiences I imagine.
But if you haven't met an unemployed dude and you like,
oh,
he's unemployed,
but he's slinging some good deck but he's wearing dockers.
That's it.
It's a deal breaker.
It might be a deal breaker.
Joe,
I don't know to baner brother that walk around in dockers.
Dudes don't give a fuck what girls where girls could wear flip flops.
You could wear dockers if you're hot,
you're hot.
A girl with big tits and dockers you'll or yeah.
All right.
Whatever.
Who Cares?
And especially once you get,
once you married and meet with somebody for a long time,
they really don't care.
Then they really don't care I think.
I think as w we don't,
I've been married with 20 something years and I don't care.
My underwear have a match.
Since middle school,
we mean you underwear hasn't brought your match.
Yeah.
Brah bottom guys don't give a fuck about,
I mean,
do you really care if,
if you know,
if a woman come to bed with matching underwear,
some women were really get into that.
I'm like,
I don't give a fuck if the pen has got a seat.
I'm cool.
I keep my shit to the seat fallout.
If a dude cares about that,
it's probably some other issues going on with guys.
Like you think so he wants to wear them?
Yeah.
Oh,
he's one of those guys.
I don't know.
I've never had a dude they would have on my panties.
You let them bigger than my means.
So they came with my dad.
If they put on my pants is going to be like a jumpsuit.
What would you do if you came home and a dude was trying on your panties?
If you came home,
like if he came home early and,
and dude had your shoes on and your pants and he was put your panties on and I
will probably slap the shit out of him.
What if he's like,
Miss Pat,
like you've got to understand like it's not that I'm not a man.
Beat the shit out of him.
What if he's like Ms Pat,
it's not that I'm not a man.
It's just this exciting.
No,
no,
I'm excited by you can get your last dick at my pants.
What if he orders his own?
We said okay.
Okay.
Okay,
okay,
but are you cool with me ordering my own?
I'm going to order a pair that fits me.
No,
that's like dating a dude with long hair.
You were seeing a dude who hears better than his girlfriend.
That's some bullshit.
I'm not dating a guy with better hair than me.
I'm not doing that.
And you're not putting all fucking bowel Dustin,
my panties.
But what if he gets his own path?
He gets his own.
Don't you think a dude who want women panties or gay?
I tried to be open minded.
I try to be open
minded to here.
There's a lot of men who even have like go through sex changes that still like
women.
They become lesbians.
I heard that.
My daughter tell,
you know,
my daughter is gay.
So a lot of her girlfriends are getting they uh,
uh,
what not girlfriends,
a lot of her gait,
gait colleagues.
I don't know if she called him colleagues.
I don't fucking know.
She called him the ones they hang out with,
they're getting a breast cut off.
Right?
Whoa.
And they and some of them getting their vagina.
Uh,
they are click click.
Tory is a cleaner is you know the little shit down at a man in the boat stretch
longer so it can be a penis.
And my daughter just telling me this shit cause I be nosy.
I was like why is your freaking they tid is cut off this or she tells me how
they're trying to form them a penis.
But I'm like isn't it a little so what's the purpose of closing?
Been doing it to your vagina.
I'm making your thing longer when you still gotta use a deal though.
Cause I don't give a fuck who you are.
You don't want no smile penis.
I agree.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well,
I know that your dick or your clit rather becomes larger if they take
testosterone,
like when you give a woman testosterone like theirs,
that's always that thing that men freak out.
Say date a female bodybuilder,
they have a clip.
Like a thumb?
Yeah.
It's not like a deck,
but it's like a thumb.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it never really,
I think it gets pretty hard.
I don't know.
I've never,
I can't really say.
I've never really been down there,
but I've seen pictures online and it looks like a tiny dick,
like a thumb sized deck.
What would you do?
Have you bought the touch somebody down there and they should feel like a
technique.
I would go.
Tell me about that.
I was asked him if you're going to tell me about that,
like what's going on down there so you'll be that calm.
You wouldn't jump off the Hay.
That'll pay.
Does somebody need to look out for?
I would be upset if,
if it was a guy that was dressing up like a woman and didn't let me know,
I'd be upset.
That's rude.
Rude.
That's beyond room.
You got her name and to eat the vagina and that thing slip for your mouth.
I said,
Dick,
well,
if it depends,
is it oversized clit or is it a dick?
Like if it's a Dick,
like if you've got a y chromosome,
if you're a dude and you're trying to pretend that you're a woman and you're not
letting anybody know that you're actually,
dude,
that's rude.
That's rude.
He caught it.
But if you're a woman and you just have a weird click,
like some people have weird fingers,
you know,
some people have long noses,
crazy long noses,
right?
Somebody's got out of a long clit.
I don't,
I don't know.
My clique is,
I don't know my,
my clicker.
I haven't seen click click.
You collect
what happens down there?
I don't really hug it.
No,
I was,
I'm on this TV show once and uh,
I had this friend who was working with and her boyfriend at the time before she
met him,
had this issue.
What are you doing?
I told you,
put that fucking thing down.
You're messing around with,
you got damn phone.
How'd you get here?
Right?
Flipped out.
She was telling me that her boyfriend had went on a date with this lady.
They got home,
they started fooling around.
He took her pants off and she had a clip,
like a pinky and he freaked the fuck out and he hit me pretty long.
He came up with some story.
He said,
oh my God.
I realized I have to pick my brother up at the airport.
Just ran out the door.
Can you choose click like a peanut lick,
bitch.
What's he pulling off of pain?
It just fell on the bed like a,
like a soft penis.
Penis allegedly.
I mean,
I don't,
you know,
that's what he said that it was like a Pinky,
but like,
who's Pankey?
You know what I'm saying?
Like everybody's pinkies like,
is it like Shaquille O'Neal's Pinky?
Oh,
that's key.
That's a,
that's not a beacon that like little Lester's Pinky,
you know,
it's like everybody's got a different size pinky,
so,
oh yeah.
The little guy from a,
what's the little movie named?
A little midget dude.
We'll be holding up his pinky.
Oh yeah.
Many me that you can deal with that clique.
Uh,
maybe it depends on the size they supposed to be.
Like you saying,
they come in all shapes and sizes.
Like what if you're sucking on it and it comes,
I don't suck them,
but we can call my daughter on threeway and she tells me
she seems to love them.
Oh boy.
Do you guys talk about that?
You know,
my daughter is,
you know,
she don't look gay.
She's the girl in the relationship.
But sometimes she,
you,
she forget that everybody ain't gay around her.
So like I bought her a cell phone because she broke her phone.
So she called me and you know,
I'm very open minded with my kids because I had him at 14 and 15 so you know,
I grew up,
they respect me.
I'm Mama,
but you know,
you know,
we kind of open minded.
She called me like,
Oh thank you for the phone.
I'm,
I could eat you.
I was like,
Bitch,
I'm your Mama.
Don't say,
oh my goodness.
But it was like in a joking form,
you know?
I guess I might call and say,
Hey,
can you get the,
uh,
can you get the vagina at your mouth?
I need to talk to you.
I mean I don't,
I don't want to see her do it.
I tried to block it out,
you know,
cause my daughter looks so much like me and I'd be like,
oh,
can you please stop kissing the cheeks with my face?
I be sad.
I don't want to imagine what she's doing with my face,
but I can guarantee you my face been on a lot of crunchy vaginas.
Crunchy.
Why crunchy?
Because black hair is crunched down there.
Slept with a black woman.
Yes.
So you know it's current.
You remember you did the joke about the lotion.
No,
that wasn't you.
What lotion that wasn't,
you don't fucking know.
We're all,
we're all looking for saying no.
You don't feel Berg.
Joe.
Bill Burner joke about lotion.
Dating a black girl as you put no cocoa butter.
I damn near Piss myself.
Especially like when we get her to have sex.
Cocoa butter make us our skin so soft.
So you get the,
you put the button a,
the cocoa butter all over you.
It makes you extra soft.
So when he rubbing on you just Ooh.
And it really works for fat girls cause you know,
got dimples in ias so it make you kind of go over the humps and Yas.
That's a fat be secret.
You didn't know that.
I did know that.
I got drunk and we woke up next to a drunk,
a fat chick.
Not all the cocoa butter it up.
Oh that's right.
She was the wrong call.
She got to be black to be cocoa.
Butter it up.
Only black girls use cocoa butter and white girls don't use coal.
We have white girlfriends,
so I don't know.
Do Yo girls?
You cocoa butter.
Black people love cocoa butter.
What is it?
What about cocoa butter or how did that get a foothold in the black market?
I have no idea.
I don't know.
We got to talk to my ancestor,
but it's good for removing scars.
It is.
That's what they say.
They say when you get pregnant,
you supposed to rub it on your stomach,
but I've had four kids and my stomach's still fucked up.
I don't,
I don't stand by that product.
Yeah,
I've heard that before.
I did hear that before that like cocoa butter
for pregnant women.
It reduces the risk of a stretch marks,
right?
Yes.
Yeah,
it does.
It doesn't work.
No,
it didn't hurt.
I talked to a doctor about that and he said it's all bullshit.
He said it's completely genetic.
You said some people they stretch out and snap back like a rubber band and
nothing happened and then the other people they can gain like a girl.
I dated a girl who gained like 10 pounds,
not much,
and she had these bear claw marks on her ass.
Crazy.
Like she got it,
but it was insane.
It didn't even make any sense.
Was like,
how did you ask it?
So fucked up from tiny towns,
probably 120 pounds.
And she had two kids,
so my stomach got really big,
but it went completely flipped out of the baby.
But her stomach still fucking wrinkle and she can't afford no tummy tuck.
So she went out and putting these gigantic tech to have a title and what?
Well it scratch Mars that she has got the tag of scratching
this.
That is a ghetto stomach live right down because you have to really get close to
know that her stomach is [inaudible] cousin.
Whoever did the tattoo hooked it up.
That's hilarious.
Brian Red Band shows up.
Hey,
how's it going?
Hey fellow,
you some nuts.
I don't want nuts.
This guy comedian makes these really good like nuts that are,
it's kind of like nature box.
That's like the next serratia cash is right there.
And I was like,
dude,
you need him sell these.
You can make a lot of money.
So ain't no drugs.
No,
there's no drug taker.
don't eat them.
Come through the microphone.
Oh that's right.
Did you have a picture of this time to no,
I don't have a picture.
A picture that,
but I was like why would you do that?
Well,
you put a gigantic gay cause she's only like a hundred and something pounds and
when she wear like tank top and there's a big ass Teigel but whoever did it
really hooked it up.
Cuts everywhere to scratch Mazda.
What?
Your stomach gets fucked up.
The tiger just scratching the shit.
Do you know her?
Still Talk to my niece every day we call it text her.
Tell her
I need to see a picture of that.
Okay,
we need a picture of that.
Let me take her next it.
Send me a picture of her a to yeah,
that sounds hilarious.
We're talking,
she was 120 pounds.
She had a kids got all fucked up and stretched out her stomach snap back,
but she has stretch marks so she got a tiger tattooed on her style.
That's perfect.
Clause is ripping apart.
The stretchmarks thinks about it's way cheaper.
Didn't get in the stomach tuck.
The stomach talks are brutal too.
If you get your skin cut off like that,
like there's a strong chance of infection.
Like people don't think of your skin as an organ,
but it's actually an organ.
Your skin isn't just,
you know,
tissue.
It's an organ.
Like,
wait,
I'm going to get my titties lift and my stomach tucked and my Nate pool a bag.
You can do it.
I mean,
I know people who've done it.
It does work.
I'm not saying that,
I'm just saying it is a,
it's a serious procedure.
I know.
You do know what you're getting in his way.
Oh,
working on it.
What are you doing?
I'm walking.
Walking.
That's it.
What else you want me to do?
God Damn you gotta Watch her G he's poured two fucking bucket to sugar and in
that fucking coffee,
why are you fucking,
how the fuck I supposed to drink my coffee?
I've only been doing this shit a little while.
How long is a little while I started in late December or January.
Have you lost any weight yet?
Like 13 pounds.
You can't tell you if that's all right.
Listen,
that's pretty good.
13 pounds.
That's actually good to do it slowly locked down 13 pounds over a couple months,
you know,
to put personal trainer.
But uh,
this dude was wearing me out.
That's what happens.
That's how I've been shaped.
In your vaginal muscles,
this is and you pissing on yourself.
Yes.
I was like,
you just can't lift my legs like dancer.
It's thank you.
You got my vagina.
Do what she did.
They did since the seventh grade,
put my goddamn links to him so I quit.
That does happen to women who've had a bunch of babies though.
Yeah,
a hard time maintaining the urine.
Like sometimes if you fucking pulling muscles that you ain't used otherwise,
of course you're going to piss on yourself.
But that's the only way to get in shape.
You gotta push your body.
I know I'm pushing my body,
but I'm like,
dude,
too much.
I don't know.
I just quit and I would just click yes and he been calling me a month.
He did it for a whole month.
Oh Ma.
And then you just woke up one day and just give me those fucking Doritos.
I ain't ain't no fucking Doritos.
Doritos.
You confusing me.
You send a miss Maxine mixed messages,
but I haven't eaten any Doritos.
Oh I see.
Cause I'm trying to lose weight.
I quit from him because I kept fucking peon on myself,
not peeing on myself working.
You know
you were just leaking a little.
I understand what you're saying.
Why don't you just get some pants that are designed to keep moisture in it?
Call a panty liner.
Yeah.
I keep them.
They like a credit card.
Credit card.
No limit.
I don't think he borrowed anything with penny line.
No.
You should probably talk to other people that are giving you financial advice.
I'm not going to work out.
No.
Panty liners are like visas card for women over 40 you don't leave home without
them.
Oh orange.
Very,
very important.
Grab your wallet before you walk out of the house.
Most women make sure they have only pantyliner.
Really?
Yeah.
Most women.
I don't know but I do.
I didn't know that most of period or they suspect no,
we use line.
Honestly.
I'll jokes aside,
they keep the seat of your pants from looking at different colors I think.
Oh,
to keep it from staining.
Yes.
Now I don't give a fuck about the bottom of my panties.
You don't know that's what it is.
Shit.
It's like an awful net.
It's a click eyelash.
Click allies.
I like that.
He's so fun Joe.
You know I,
I gotta tell you I used to be scared of you.
Right?
Why?
I don't know.
You got that top of song and see,
I know you do that.
MSF can I see my free cams?
What is Shit you be doing?
You know the karate shit you be doing and I can be with the fuck out.
I was kind of intimidating.
You walk around your chest all big and shit,
you know Nice,
nice bodies.
You look,
you look tough.
And I was like oh I'm scared of this dude.
You're not getting here the first I was like he's cool as fuck.
I wanted to kiss you the first time when I was still you can kiss me.
No,
not today.
Not Today.
I didn't want her to kiss me with too many panty.
Let her talk to fuck up.
Did she send me the picture of the Tiger town?
Get her.
I just got their phone number.
What is the deal with panty liners liners?
Cause I've never seen him on a girl before.
And then recently this young girl had them and she's like,
oh no,
I wear them every day.
Everybody keep you fresh down there.
They come with,
they come with,
they come with deodorize,
you know deodorizer.
Yes.
Deodorizer some raising your underwear,
but some girls panties smell good.
Like they're pussies.
Think that's what I,
yeah,
you don't know the trick behind getting them panties to smell like dad getting
their vagina smells.
Oh,
vagina got ahold of him.
Do you agree all,
I don't if there's a very limited study group.
I mean,
how many look this fucking 7 billion people on the planet.
3.9 billion women.
Dammit.
I'm telling you about real puts said,
I'm not talking about what you read.
What you read.
Real.
Yeah.
Real
well,
yeah.
I'm,
I'm sure it comes on an odor,
but not a bad odor.
No,
no.
It's just a natural,
older,
you don't like the ocean.
You know how to ocean smell when you stick your nose to one of those seashells,
fishing,
whatever.
Fuck you.
I'll vagina.
Got Old,
older,
right.
No matter how much you watch it.
And I'm like,
no.
Yeah,
thanks.
Would smells?
What does it smell?
The coffee has a smell.
I'm not talking about,
oh,
your stem.
If it's a stench indication that something wrong with it.
You know what's fucked up about a yeast infections.
A lot of use infections.
Not all of them.
Obviously they come from girl having sex with more than one guy that which is
crazy.
Like what a weird thing that like if you have sex with one guy like that guys
come in,
your vagina is okay,
but if two different guys come get your job,
it becomes a use infection.
I don't know about that.
And then when they dangerous,
they hurt.
They hurt.
My friend used to,
I used to have a friend.
I still talk to these two infections.
Hurt.
Yeah.
They itch like a motherfucker.
Know it's like crabs.
You ever had crabs?
Nope.
You've Adam.
Yes,
sure.
But what a yeast infection is on the inside.
So you gotta try to rub it.
Ooh,
it's,
it's really you,
you,
uh,
if it's,
if it gets really bad,
you could really probably scratched the skin out the inside if you don't go get
it treated.
You know,
that's a funny thing that people are not worried about saving is an organism
that no one was worried about saving his crabs because crabs were on the verge
of extinction because people are shaving their pubic hairs.
That's it.
The real issue today,
there's very few crabs left in the world in the wild.
Uh,
I agree.
No,
but he used to be,
I'm serious.
He used to be a big thing like back in the 70s,
fucking everybody had crabs.
Why?
Because they all had goddamn shrubbery grown their underwear.
They had huge bushes.
Nobody trimmed their pussy.
Nobody trimmed the deck.
It was just a chaos down there.
So two people would have sex and it would be like to jungles was going in there.
What do you mean?
Somebody had to go get the crabs and put them there for Dental Omega in the
jungle.
They just didn't go and say,
Hey,
this is my dick today and jump on it.
Well,
that's the case with every disease.
Every disease had to start with one person,
right?
Allegedly following with wildlife.
And a lot of them start with um,
uh,
like today's diseases,
big,
big portion of today's.
He started with agriculture.
Like,
um,
like a lot of chickens,
diseases come from,
um,
uh,
livestock.
A lot of diseases come from pigs,
swine flu,
famous flu,
bird flu.
Well,
I mean,
any disease,
diseases.
I mean,
it's all really the same thing.
If you think about it.
They'll have to start with a person.
The difference between venereal diseases sexually transmitted,
but you could transmit venereal diseases through blood too.
If you figured out a way to get someone's blood inside of you.
It's just whatever the disease is getting it from one person and one person,
it had to have an original host.
Okay.
It's fucked up,
right?
A lot of them come from like,
when you see factory farms like,
uh,
like livestock farms and bird farms and tell you that's where a lot of diseases
come from.
They morph because there's a giant population of animals live in their own shit.
You know,
what make you think crabs is on the verge of extinction?
There's articles written about it.
I hope the instances of genital crabs have drastically reduced since,
uh,
the implementation of pornographic,
visual,
vagina trimming and penis trimming.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
because people would shave their pussies and let it wild.
Yeah.
100%.
Has got an Afro pick in it.
I like to see you like God dammit shaving your vagina is for young girls.
You know what I'm saying?
At a certain point in time it's over what I do,
but I don't do it at my house because I don't want to clean it up.
So I wait till I'm at a hotel on the road.
No.
So when you're on the road,
then you start burning down the house.
That shit is hard.
You know,
I got black hair that she'd curl up on your walls and it's hard to get out.
I see.
The jheri curl was stuck on a wall before Brazil.
I have not seen Jerry curls.
I mean,
you know,
go adding,
I'm serious.
This shit stick to the wall.
So I wait until I'm on the road and let somebody else clean it up.
So when you're on the road though,
you do trimming up.
You got a Tux was out of the picture.
I'm trying to see
did she said no,
no,
not yet.
She worked at night.
All right.
Put that phone down.
Okay.
Flip that shit up.
Flip it over to,
okay.
She's got one of those things.
She can't help it.
She's getting Neil Brennan disease.
You start fucking with your phone every five seconds.
So do you shave your wiener?
I Shit,
I don't know when my Dick doesn't get herring,
but the,
the legs,
the top does.
Oh,
the top.
Yeah.
I shaved my balls and the above the deck.
But the deck itself does not,
not,
not around,
they're like the trunk of it and it doesn't get that.
I get a little couple raggedy Harris,
but it's really the top area that you have to be 40 so hair is good when you
over 40 but when the wind go between your leg,
you warm,
the wind goes between your legs.
No,
go between Malaya come a tie this together.
But I'm just saying it whistles.
So when you get to like any sort of a windy intersection,
more protected because the shave,
they keep it warm down there.
I see.
Well girls would always say that they would put like a,
but they put on their winter,
20 girls would put on weight for the winter.
I'm like,
this,
you're just fucking lazy.
Yeah.
Well what?
I'm staring
at our 20.
Never heard that.
No,
I never heard that for some,
some girls like to get real fin the summer,
so they look sexy and you know where a little cute outfits and then the winter
comes along.
They go,
all right,
it's time to fatten up for the fucking snow.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
I wish I can get them for the summer.
I'm working on it.
So when you say you're working on it though,
like I walk every day,
Joe.
Right.
And um,
I do a lot of weight in a little bit of bicycle.
I'm doing about an hour and a half a day,
about five days a week.
When I'm home.
I went this morning.
Oh yeah.
Yes.
What'd you do this morning?
I walked for 45 minutes and rode the bike for 20 and I did 20 jumping jacks.
Oh,
that's good.
Yes.
That's good stuff.
I just think so.
Do you watch what you eat?
Yeah.
Watch it.
Go right in your mouth.
I ate strawberries and an anomaly this morning.
Oh,
that's good.
So you're eating healthy.
I'm trying.
It's hard when you're on the road and lonely and get a bucket of ice cream and
call your husband.
He don't have ice cream.
I don't eat ice cream.
You know what I'm saying?
Not just like food.
I mean food is great,
but when I'm by myself and I can more so I go out to fancy or restaurant cause I
don't have my fucking keys.
They're in my ear,
you know?
I don't have to say,
Hey,
if I'm going to buy this steak for me,
I got to buy you one to him by my fucking self.
So I go out and not splurge.
Right.
Yeah.
I see.
Sometimes I got a bad habit of spending a bad habit of spending.
Yeah.
I like to do shit,
you know,
like go eat and shopping.
I get bored.
You mean when you're on the road?
Yeah,
home too.
How often it home too.
I'm on the road about three times a month.
Three weekends.
That's a lot.
Yes,
a lot.
Now in live?
In Indianapolis,
right.
Are you willing to Annapolis you work out in Indianapolis,
like your,
your material,
that's where you do stuff?
Yes.
Yeah,
a little bit.
A little bit,
yeah.
I drive down to Kentucky to,
cause the people always mortise.
They also owned the club in Kentucky,
so I drive the drive hour and a half.
Oh,
that's not bad.
I didn't know that.
Indianapolis was only an hour and a half from Kentucky.
Louisville.
Really?
Some lube on hour and a half away.
Yeah,
he just left there.
Hmm.
Who was you with?
Tiffany.
And who else?
Tiffany had his shin.
Tony Hinchcliffe.
I no,
it was del,
right?
Yeah,
it was him.
Yeah.
So,
but that's why I work on my material.
That's nice though.
You're working three weekends a month.
That's nice.
It's getting better help.
You know,
the podcast world have really been supportive.
I went to Chicago after I did chores and all of these fit fuckers from a GM came
out.
I was like,
holy fuck.
I can tell the different people from the different park as your people are
always in fucking shape.
Well that's good.
Yeah.
And they just so motivated.
They'd be like,
Oh miss pat,
you can do,
I'm like go fuck yourself and get off my back.
So they sat there trying to give you help.
I mean the fans are the ones who stay with me,
you know?
Those are the ones they really like.
You fuck everybody else,
you know?
Well I guarantee you we can get you a trainer in Indianapolis and won't make You
pee herself.
Really?
Yeah.
We'll find somebody.
Find somebody.
Why?
Why is everything gotta be free?
Don't you make money?
How much chemical free said it like three times.
Three.
Why for for you?
You just said you work.
Oh,
how expensive can they be?
Update.
They cost money lining.
Yeah,
I know you're doing well.
I hear,
I hear things are going to fuck you hear that?
Oh,
here.
Are you selling tickets?
I have people coming to see you.
They love them.
I'll come in and see me.
Thank you.
So,
uh,
Joe Case,
you just say,
Hey,
y'all supposed to miss pat and I'll give you a shout out on my show,
my show.
What about you?
You give them a shout out on Twitter.
That's all you have to do.
Shout out if you want to train me and I don't have to pee on myself.
Just two months.
He come to my house.
If someone can prove to you that they can get you in shape,
we start paying them then yeah.
Then you'll pay them.
The last guy was getting me a shape and you were paying him?
Yeah.
The thing is you got to knock on my door and make me come out.
Got a knock on your door.
You got to wake you up?
Nope.
Does he have to feed you?
Put your shoes on?
I'm working on it.
Okay.
Joe got,
Damn.
You sound like a step daddy.
Just trying to find out where your line is.
I'm trying to find out where your aligners lazy but I'm working on it so someone
just has to kind of get you to do it.
You know what it is.
I get started and then I don't see no results.
Like I have a problem where I would get on the scale every fucking day and he
was like state or fuck off their scale cause you know you drink water,
that's water weight and I was like,
I spent all this fucking time at the gym and I didn't a little shit.
So he can't just lose weight and continuously,
I mean I know but I'm an ex drug dealer so everything is was fast in my life and
I like shit to be fast in my life.
But it wasn't fast to get big,
you got to get well the same reason he got sick.
I woke up like this,
I don't remember.
Caney no 100 and some pounds during my marriage,
my marriage,
we just,
we,
we used to have a lot of sex and eat taco bell and two years later we woke up
fat.
That's,
I don't remember ever changing panty sizes.
One day I just went from a 16 to in my twenties.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
What's a 16 large,
what's the size?
16 panties?
A normal size,
but I don't know if that means like what,
what size person would that be?
A hundred pounds.
120 pounds.
For me,
a 16 is about one 75 where you were wearing one 75 when I met my husband and
then somewhere along the line,
straight out of the military.
So he wasn't fat either.
You know,
I tell you,
I told you my husband was a Vegan and he lost all that weight.
He gained,
gained it all back.
Oh No,
we don't.
We don't eat meat.
He just went on a cookie died.
Cookie Diet does happen.
Um,
he gained about 60 pounds back and since the last time you were here.
Yeah.
That's insane.
That's fucking unhealthy.
I keep telling him that's the,
having your titties go up and down like that.
You're going to have a heart attack.
The heart attack is the real concern.
It's not the titties.
Yeah.
Two is you're going to get wrecked.
You lose and gain that much weight.
Your body doesn't know what the fuck back in the gym.
Yeah.
Well you can't gain,
that's a scary thing.
I tell you what happened.
He went,
um,
his gout flare it up.
So when his gout flareup,
he can't do shit.
You'll never had gout.
I have a friend that is some painful shit.
My husband can't do shit.
He's told just be,
it looked like it fucking talking to you and just read to you.
Take medication for it.
Well it's his diet.
It's his diet.
What about the Diet?
Like what,
you know,
they say God,
these two,
see it was like a king's disease.
I used to affect a lot of like royal people back in the day cause they let them
in on him.
That man overseas,
what's his name?
Khan.
Jewel will the manual.
Yeah,
him.
He got gout.
The new one.
Kim Jong.
Ooh.
Yeah,
yeah,
he does gout.
Yeah,
that's what they say.
It's associated with people that are overweight,
but it's also associated with specific diets.
Diets that are rich and certain foods.
I forget what it is,
but I know some wine has something to do with it.
You don't drink wine.
What's the symptoms?
I don't know.
You get like joint pain.
My friend who has it,
he's got like,
he gets really painful heels.
Like his feet swell up.
My husband had in his left tall in his left toe only.
Yup.
That's the only place it flare up.
Really?
Yup.
That's weird.
My father in law just passed in November and um,
he had it all over his body.
He had it in his arms.
His hands,
like my mother in law got it in her arms,
but everybody in my husband's family.
Got It.
Hmm.
Okay.
Here's what it says.
There are a number of factors,
risk factors for gout.
The more risk factors a person has a greater risk of developing gap when
examining a patient to take the following risk factors into consideration to
ensure a proper diagnosis.
Hyper,
hyper.
You're a see me classified as a serum uric acid.
Yeah.
Uric acid.
That's one of the things that has to do that for some reason.
Other has to do with diet,
right?
Yeah.
Family history,
age,
gender,
gout affects men more than women.
Ethnicity.
The incidences of gouty arthritis and a core comorbid conditions varies by
ethnicity in the US.
Hispanics and African Americans who have features of metabolic syndrome are more
likely to develop gout.
Obesity.
What's that?
What are you putting that up for?
I got a trainer.
What?
What is that?
Okay.
Give some training or new,
I don't even know.
That guy sucks.
It could not even
just one trainer.
He was fat.
That's not good.
Hey,
whoa.
Wait belt to like a girl and I was like,
I'm not going to keep paying your fat ass crystals.
This is the other thing.
Yeah,
it forms crystals and that's what my friend,
that's why it hurt so bad.
My husband say it feels like somebody is just fucking got fired to your skin.
Alcohol consumption.
Uh,
especially beer.
Pure drinking beer.
It says Purina.
I don't mean that's not even the dog food.
Purina,
Purina rich foods,
especially red meat and shellfish.
High Fructose Laden foods like high fructose corn syrup,
crash diets,
crash diets.
I'm going to tell him that including high protein fat diets,
starting uric acid lowering therapy without anti-inflammatory coverage.
Hmm.
Bedrest,
often postoperative and all those things trigger nothing can stop the pain.
Nothing like Tylenol.
No.
They can't give you anything.
They'll give something to try to calm it down,
but nothing like if my husband get it.
What did he,
what did he drink?
He drinks something to make his calm down.
Oh.
Um,
uh,
organic PR.
What is organic cranberry juice or organic cranberry juice.
Yeah.
Why don't you percent cranberry juice?
Calms it down.
You know,
most cranberry juices like cranberry juice cocktail,
which is like not a cat tail because the one he buys like $9,
like seven to $8 at Kroger down the organic.
I that helps.
Yes.
And he drinks it every day.
Shit,
it's,
it's very tall.
It's taught,
I'm sorry.
It's Tart cranberry juice.
That's what it is.
Well,
cranberry juice cocktail.
Like most people think their drink drinking cram,
juror number,
just shit.
You're drinking a lot of sugar.
Yes you are.
But my husband drinks the tarts and he drinks like maybe he drinks it like at
least once a week to keep the flareups.
He can tell now when they're about to flare up and he'd get on his cranberry
juice and it'll go away.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
It doesn't that hurt with women who have urinary tract infections as well.
Yeah.
That shit feel like gone to real.
Does it?
You know a gonorrhea.
It feels like,
I know what a lot of shifts.
Aye.
I ain't always had healthcare,
but urinary tract infections,
that's a one thing that women who take cranberry juice to do that cleans your
vagina.
You want to keep it down because if you get like if it,
if it gets really bad and you go to Piss,
you could run out in the bathroom.
Whoa.
That shit hurt.
Yeah.
Why does it hurt?
Because it's inflamed and it's burning.
It's like if you took your wiener,
I'll let me stuck a lighter too.
Oh,
I was just trying to demonstrate the pain.
I call a wiener.
Well Dick.
Oh,
okay.
Wait a style like
to me wiener is sexy.
Do you?
If your husband's like,
listen,
baby boomers slang my wiener your way.
Well my husband don't allow me to talk in the bedroom because my voice is deep
in the bedroom.
He's like fucking clearly off.
Throw tells you not to talk in the bedroom.
Listen,
we're going to walk through the threshold of silence.
We do our fucking
trash.
Whoa.
What were you saying?
Fuck me.
Oh,
come on hard mother fucker.
You ain't on shit to make you feel like young when you're having sex.
Wow.
All that deep talk.
He don't like he said when I lay down and my boobs go up on my neck,
I really sounded like a man
looking at me like that.
You know I'm fat so my team is going to roll up on my neck from land down.
Do they ever cover your eyes?
Oh,
they probably could.
Like one time I woke up and I thought my husband was choking me but it was my
titties up under my neck.
Wow.
Your titties were under your neck heavy that you thought your husband was
choking him?
I thought he kinda like had his hand around my neck and then I woke up and it
was my fucking,
I wasn't choking,
but you know how you feel something on you when you sleep,
so,
so that also affects the way you talk.
So you guys have deals?
Yeah,
I don't talk to talking about them.
Do you have any deals for him?
Like he can't talk anywhere else.
Like you should have a room where he can,
he's got to shut the fuck up.
You can't just have a room where only he gets to talk.
Well he knows,
you know what I'm saying?
You should give him a room,
but you got to get a room to,
well,
I'm working on getting a bedroom so I don't have to watch them.
Bullshit ass TV that he watched.
Oh,
so you're working on getting a separate bedroom?
I have one of my nieces just got to wait till they leave.
That's the beginning of the end.
You get separate bedrooms.
Well,
we're not going to,
I'm going to go there and watch TV and relax.
That's it.
Yeah.
No,
I have to sleep with my husband.
I love my husband Joe.
I believe he's my hero.
You know most people wait on somebody to in on a white horse.
He came in on a Nissan and got me out the ghetto.
He gave a bitch.
Hell,
you didn't punch a bitch.
And I hear Friday,
no gun real,
no crabs,
no baby mama,
none of that bullshit.
Sounds like a great guy.
He is a great guy.
All you can't talk in the bedroom.
Shit I gotta do.
Okay,
so then you get this new bedroom.
Then he's got to shut the fuck up and the new bedroom and then a new bedroom.
You can just talk all kinds of crazy shit.
You know ms paths bedroom.
When she gets to talk,
go get me a vibrator and talk to the vibrator.
He won't tell me to shut the fuck up.
You don't have to go that crazy.
But I'm just saying love vibrators.
I believe you.
I have never used a vibrator.
I just never,
you've never tried one?
I've been fucking since I was 12 I don't have no problem getting laid.
I believe that as well.
Did you ever get curious?
Like what's he was all the fuss was all about.
Well No,
nothing.
Cause you know,
you know what they say.
They say what does your dad,
you're going to meet God and going to flash your life back in your face.
I don't want to see that vibrator scene when I have to get into him.
I wouldn't worry about it.
Let me think about all the other shit got in your head.
Well I got an excuse for that yourself with your tents?
Yeah.
What you don't want to look at guns said,
oh I needed a nut.
Why not?
No,
I don't want to do that.
God's the one who gave you this desire to come?
Well,
I know that.
I mean that was just joking.
I know.
Like vibrators,
you don't like them.
No,
you don't know because you haven't tried them.
Right.
I know that's what my girlfriends say.
But I've always had sex with somebody.
I mean who goes up?
My titty Joe.
Me.
So you demand certain activities having sex that the vagina is that the
vibrators not capable of fulfilling Zach Lou,
I'm gonna talk to,
I get it.
I see what you're saying.
A lot of sense.
I mean,
I think they're cute.
You think of vibrators?
Cute.
I've seen him in our sizes.
I hosted a vibrator party one time.
You hosted a vibrator party?
Yes.
And up at the time this,
the new one was you can uh,
it had a suction cup on it.
So you just stick into the toilet and you fuck yourself anywhere in the house.
It just stick to the wall.
And it was crazy.
And women were buying the shit.
An outsizes Joe.
Oh,
like this,
like this.
I had a friend who had a girlfriend who couldn't come without her.
She got addicted to it and so he wasn't shit.
He would fuck the shit out of her.
And then she was like,
oh,
give me that thing.
Yeah.
Hitachi's are known for that because they're so powerful that they pretty much
make it so it's numbed down there that they only have to have that feeling too
to come now because Hitachi's or like those really strong ones.
They plug in this little law and those things.
Just Tachi.
Is it a massager?
That girl's uses a library.
It's a famous,
uh,
it's one of the oldest massagers.
It looks kind of like a,
a like a long a ice cream cone or something fucking talking about.
The one I saw today was plastic and they just,
yeah,
those look like dicks.
Well,
the one that he's talking about a lot of them too.
Oh yeah,
the lesbian daughter.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
My other daughter is 16.
I hope she ain't got no vibrate.
The one that's weird.
Like,
so lesbians,
we'll use vibrators and strap ons and all that shit,
but they don't want no,
no,
no.
They want something inside them.
No,
that's why I have a joke.
That's why I have a joke.
I was asked my daughter,
I was like,
why are you gay?
I mean,
if,
if the TDS is your thing,
go out and get a fat boy that's a Hitachi and it's super powerful.
Like if you have it full blast,
well it's not supposed to,
you don't.
You just put on a clip.
It's not supposed to be for that though.
It's supposed to be for your back.
Oh God.
Yeah.
I don't know nothing about that type of sex.
I'm just straight up and down and go to sleep straight up and down and then go
to sleep.
If someone buys one for you,
where are you?
At least try it and we're not on it.
I'm not doing that bullshit.
I'm a Christian.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Christians don't use fat.
They have Jesus once.
What if one of them is blessed?
Fuck up,
not even going to vibrate.
How does that work?
Are Christians allowed to masturbate?
I don't know.
I'm not a real Christian.
I'm a Christian.
You're not a real Christian,
but you are a Christian Christian.
I am.
I believe in God and Jesus.
I am but not been baptized 25 times.
So of course I'm a Christian 25 times.
Why were you baptized 25 times?
Well,
my momma had a skiing in the head back in the day when you went out to churches,
cared about you.
So if you go to church and he was like,
we was poor.
So if you had problems with your financial problems,
if he had financial problems and you join the church and the church will write
you a check for your finances that month.
Really?
Yeah,
there was a black church.
That's amazing.
Well that's why black church don't give out money without interviews.
No churches give up interview Monday without interviews.
But that's a,
that is a beautiful function of a church though,
that they could actually,
how does that work?
So my mama would take us,
it was five of us and she would take us to get,
we would join
the church,
you know,
like we really to come and you know,
and they will pay our light bill,
I'll rent or whatever.
And so they,
the,
the past,
I always wanted to baptize you.
So my momma had a scheme where she would sit in these churches up to get us
baptize and get help.
So you,
you bring the kid in,
you say,
I want my child to get baptized.
I got a lot of financial,
Angela,
no,
you scheduling.
She'll go to the church,
asked for help and and that they always try to talk you into joining cause you
need memos to keep going.
And my mom was like,
yeah I joined,
you know and get baptized or whatever.
I don't know how to meet him.
Went down,
I just showed up for the baptism.
So you would show up?
They'd baptize.
You dunk it in the water and then what happens?
They give you some money.
They give my mama to money.
How much money?
I don't know.
I was a kid.
I didn't even know that.
I didn't even realize,
I didn't even realize this shit wasn't right.
Wasn't abnormal until I was on my phone.
My girlfriend probably about eight years ago and I'm talking to probably like 10
years ago and we was talking about baptism and I was like,
I got baptized 25 times.
She's like,
who the fuck baptize you 25 times.
I was like,
I met Sammy,
was you baptized?
She was like once.
I was like,
why?
And I said,
oh that was a fucking skiing.
Did you ever talk to your mom about it?
My mom is dead.
My Mama died when I was 30 when she was 39 I was 16 with two kids.
She had diabetes.
Wow.
That's one more reason to try to get you.
I wasn't fat.
She was 98 pounds.
Damn 98 pounds.
Never was fat.
Yes,
she was an alcoholic.
My Mom,
I think my Mama,
they say diabetes when you ain't got no health care,
no insurance.
They just put whatever appeals you were taking that with the motherfucker data.
But I think my mom just died of a broken heart.
She had a rough life.
You know,
she had five kids before she was 23 she was uneducated.
She was in a very abusive relationship with my daddy.
I mean,
we never had ships.
We always lived in places where we got evicted because she lived off welfare.
I mean,
she just,
she,
I mean,
I'm not going to say she'd never had a chance.
She just had a bad,
like whatever,
whatever she was,
it was,
it's a cycle.
So whatever her parents,
whatever she saw her parents do,
she went on and did it.
And so that my sister and told to do,
oh,
I changed my life.
Yeah,
you broke the cycle.
Yeah.
But did that occur to you while you were young and when you had kids?
Like my,
I'm doing the same thing my mom was doing.
Yes.
Like my Mama would have me at a really young age,
like a lightened cigarettes at five or six lighting her cigarettes.
Yes.
And,
but I was told in school,
I'm like,
well I probably have about six or seven and we was taught in school not to
smoke.
I remember that Joe,
cool guy with the cigarettes.
You remember the Little Camera Camera?
That's what I'm talking about.
Remember how cool he was.
But in school you was taught not to smoke.
Cigarettes will kill you.
So that always stuck in my head.
But when my mom would send me in in the room and me and the kitchen and light
her cigarettes after stole and she was like,
make sure you pull it to time.
And I'm like,
bitch,
they just told me I'm going to die.
I didn't say that to her.
That's it in my head.
You know.
He shot some it through.
She was telling you to they nail it to get it going.
I don't fucking know.
But my sister smoked everything in the book from this year.
I inhale.
You know what high she,
the reason why she stopped me from doing it because I would go in there and
fucking Friday fucking cigarette and she was slapped the shit.
She smoked Winston's so already that shit is super strong so we'll be want to
spit on like who'd been a confidence shit.
My sister got muscles are proud of smoking at eight years old.
How old were you when she was getting you this lighter cigarettes?
Probably about,
well my sister probably like eight.
So she two years older than me.
So you were six years old and she was telling you to take a hit off a second.
Yes,
we did it every day.
Fuck,
that's crazy.
We need it.
If we knew how to pull her Jean and she's drunk Jan and water.
So we would go back there and make her a drink all the time.
She would tell her to make her a drink.
Ah Yes.
And I used to always say everything I say you motherfuckers do,
I'm never going to do it.
I don't smoke or drink and is,
you know what I always said my momma made me think and she did everything unsexy
just like she wasn't like most moms like and she smoked a cigarette.
She didn't hold it like you know how you saw most women hold?
She had that bitch like a joint cause she smoked a lot of weed and I said why
you do everything like a man?
I didn't say that to her but like she never drank out of glass.
She always dropped out of a quart bottle.
So I was like,
she'd do everything like a fucking man.
Like she never told her purse.
She always told a wallet,
a man's wallet in my back pocket.
Really?
So everything she did,
I was like,
I can't do this bullshit.
I believe from heaven.
So many kids at a young age probably want to have nothing to do with sexy.
Just stay the fuck away from me with all their Dick.
That just gets me in trouble.
She's do some repulsive shit so forth.
Well,
you know she,
she had five key is really young because her,
my daddy is,
was nine years older than her,
like eight years older than her,
like my kids' father was.
And I didn't even realize that until one day I was out here,
put some shit together and I had my birth certificate and I was like,
ah,
this motherfucker got my mama young.
Like my baby daddy got me young.
It's so crazy.
It's such a repeating cycle.
It is a repeated side until somebody open their eyes and say Holy Shit,
we all headed,
I'm headed like these people.
What made you realize and what,
what do you think was like the catalyst to get you to stop?
When I had my kids,
when I had my,
you know,
I had the first baby at 14 and that's the first time I ever felt like I was
loved.
I,
that's one of the reasons why I kept the baby cause you know the baby and I got
a book deal so I don't give away all the stores.
But that's one of the reason when I gave birth to her,
I kept her because he was married.
This lady showed up at my door.
I was like,
this is my fucking husband.
You breaking it by it.
But to me,
I was going to finally have somebody in my life that loved me and I never,
I didn't have to worry about betraying me.
So that's why I kept that baby because I knew that baby will love me
unconditionally because I never felt like I was alone until,
I mean,
when I had the baby,
I was 14 and I've given birth by myself.
He wasn't there.
He showed up in the neck,
then the hospital with his girlfriend and his new girlfriend,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
So you,
you like consciously felt like you could raise this baby from the time it was
little and it would love you.
I,
yeah,
but I didn't realize the finance attached witty,
but yeah.
You know,
it's almost like a baby dog.
That's how you kind of looked at it was a cabbage bad.
I never got,
but I,
my carriage pack,
the carriage pay.
Kids don't eat these motherfucker really aid.
So I had to go out and get a job.
You got a book deal?
Yeah,
I'm calling about when did this happen?
Uh,
after I left you
as well,
the writer hurt me or it's your fear.
So she went to an agency and told them to listen to the Rogan Park Cas.
And so she listened to the Rhogam Park cats and then I did Marin's and then they
listen to him and then the agent picked me up.
So got the agent fromU and m seal.
The deal of with all the podcast is together and I thought I did Martin
Marathons and I was shocked too.
I was like,
ah,
y'all going about his shit?
So are you going to write it yourself?
Your now
he say click,
click,
click.
Tory's notorious is a Greek Roman clip.
I don't know what you fucking is,
but the Tories maximus,
the lady who found me on Ari park cast,
she's writing it.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
So you just will tell her the stories driven talking.
Well,
I sold the book last time.
I looked right around the last time I was here after I was here.
So we riding,
we almost done with the first chapter so far was so talking about three,
four times a week.
So does she talk to you on the phone?
On the phone and then she just,
did she record it and transcribe it?
So I'm quite sure she do.
I mean,
I just,
I just don't fucking know.
We'll go in the book.
Right.
I got a GED.
I just tell her the stories and then she'd go from there.
Like,
um,
it's kind of funny because,
you know,
she opened doors in my life that I've had close so long that they were,
that's a lot of pain after,
you know,
I only seen his later a couple of times and I'm just opening these doors.
So a lot of times we cried together,
but we also laugh in a lot of time.
I hang up from when she'd come back.
She's like,
Oh,
you okay.
And I'm like,
I'm a fucking case.
This is 30 years ago.
But,
and I think the reason why emotion is there,
because I hadn't had to deal with it all of these years,
you know,
I,
you can,
you know,
when you,
when you compress shit,
it's okay until my fucking crack that door open.
So I deal,
I do a lot.
Well I did a lot of crying with her.
Yeah.
That's the case with a lot of people never recalled like ancient things that
happened to them.
Like you don't even realize how much it affected you until you start talking
about it.
Then you start crying and realize like,
wow,
that played a major
part in fucking me up.
Yeah.
You know,
and,
and it,
I'm 42 I mean I'm 42 years old and I,
and you know,
I still can remember my mama saying white people is better than you.
So for years,
Joe,
I was scared of white people.
I never had to deal with,
y'all didn't come to my fucking house.
I didn't go out looking for y'all.
So I didn't really have to deal with white people until I moved to Indianapolis
in my comedy career.
Cause there was no urban scene because when I first started comedy I was on an
urban singing.
So you don't see white people coming in too many Urban's little small hole in
the wall.
So when I got to Austin,
funny that urban is black.
Uh Yeah.
How the fuck did that happen?
How did it become urban?
I have no idea.
Urban means city,
like city.
Everybody lives in the fucking city.
I mean most half the world lives in a city.
Like how weird is it that people,
they did that.
Oh my people by people.
Do you think it's like a euphemism for black?
They wanted to say I have a nice way of saying black.
So they came up with urban?
Yes.
Urban crime.
Hey Eben crying.
Yeah.
Inner city.
So you started doing urban rooms?
Yeah.
When I first started,
so when I,
my husband job transferred us to Indianapolis.
It was no singing there.
So I had to go into the,
to the mainstream club,
which was more at ease and,
and crackers and stuff.
And,
and I would just,
you know,
kind of fucking chuck and we'll do what I was doing to one of the managers,
Avery.
Hey Avery,
he love your podcast.
And he was,
I would tell him these stories,
he's like,
you should really talk about your life.
And when I started to talk about my life,
you know,
people,
they would just come to me.
Oh,
you so funnels.
Get your fucking hands on me.
I wouldn't say that to them,
but in my mind my mind was fucked up because she said,
don't white people are better than you.
Never look them in eye.
Well,
who fucking said that to you?
Your mom.
Your mom said white people are better than you.
Look them in the eye.
What did she mean by that?
I don't know.
You know by,
but they're better than you.
They are.
That's what she said.
Because you know,
I guess my momma was born in the 40 so she was a part of that whole civil right
movement.
And you know,
you had a lot of people that believe that bullshit that we are different.
They were different back then.
So she taught me why people was better than me.
Never look,
you and I,
and until I moved to Indianapolis,
I could never look them in the eye.
And I told my husband his story.
He was like,
we all the fucking sign.
Cause you know,
white women are so friendly.
So they were run up to me and kissed me.
Oh you're so funny.
In my mind,
look bit you and get your Mfa Game I'm in with.
Choke the shit out you.
I know what's fucked up.
I mean we don't,
we don't think about it in perspective,
but we are as close to 1940s as the 1940s where to slavery.
You don't think about it like that.
But that's reality.
I mean slavery ended in 1875 you think about that thing of 1875 to 1940 you
know,
it's not that much time.
It's not that much time.
So five years,
you know,
whatever plus or minus 10 years,
not that much time.
And then you go from 1940 you know you're dealing with 17 years to today,
74 years,
five years from 1940 and give or take a few here or there.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That's weird when you really think about it like that's not that far away where
people owned people in this fucking country.
Yeah,
and your mother grew up in that goes,
you know the reverberations of that error and the civil war.
I mean people going to war over that and that's fucked up.
If you really stop and think about it,
your mom was as close to God Damn Lincoln being president as we are born in 40
I think.
My Dad was born in 42 and she was born in 49 and my dad was born in 30
something.
My Dad was born in at 30 and I don't fucking know.
He died when he was almost 70 but she died at 39
yeah,
she was as close to Lincoln being president as we are to Eisenhower being
present,
which is fucking weird.
That is weird.
As weird to think of because it's just,
we look at history,
when you start thinking about slavery,
we start thinking about Abraham Lincoln.
That seems so long ago,
impossibly long ago.
But then when you,
you know,
you,
you do the numbers and you go,
wait a minute.
Oh,
the shit,
whoa.
1865 like that is not 1875.
That's not that long ago is that it's not,
it's just not,
it's not that long ago.
It's weird.
It's weird that it's not,
but it really isn't.
It's just,
uh,
th th th the human like the,
the,
the toll that,
that sort of life paid or that the had to be a paid by people of having slavery
and having just rampant racism throughout this country and having two completely
different groups of people,
white people and black people and that black people,
literally your mother telling you white people are better than you.
The toll of that,
like the,
the,
the impact of that God damn,
that's going to take a long time to sell the fuck down.
Well,
I mean,
I'm getting over it now.
I realize we all the same,
you know,
you know better than me,
you know
you are,
but you think a lot and you're very smart person that you were exposed to a lot
of different things.
Yeah.
I mean,
think about how many people just don't get that message.
You know what?
And I took my brother to show in Lafayette,
Indiana.
I did around Thanksgiving,
my family came up.
So I take my,
my,
my brother them,
they just think I'm some open mic.
They don't really know what I do,
you know,
cause I don't see my family a lot.
So I take my brother to Lafayette,
Indiana and 300 some white people come out,
white people,
we don't want to be like people.
I don't have that many black people that come out and see me.
So I told him,
I said,
I knew it wasn't going to be any black people.
So I brought black people with me,
my family.
And so I'm telling these jokes about my life,
how we grew up.
My brother over there crying,
laughing.
And so when I finished and we get in the car,
he said,
reb,
Chaim crackles let you talk to them.
Like Dad,
your street name.
They don't call me Patricia.
Like your whole family calls you by your
name.
I thought it was nuts.
I was like,
Tony,
nobody say crackers anymore.
And they're white people.
Okay.
Isn't that a club crackers?
Crap club correctly.
But that also right people
crackers and it's filled with white people.
God Damn.
Yeah.
That's gotta be weird having your brother call your cracker or a rabbit rather.
I tried to stop him,
but me and my cousins call me rabbit cause I don't know.
That's where we're going to name the book rabbit.
Oh really?
Yes.
We're going to name the book rabbit.
Ms Pat,
Aka Rabbit.
I don't know how it's gonna go,
but I know they decided on rabid.
They think rabbit gotta pop to it.
Yeah,
you should use your real name,
the name you use onstage.
Don't let them use any other name.
Ms Pat,
make sure it's miss pat is in the title somehow or another,
otherwise people won't find it.
Okay.
You know,
thank you for telling me.
You get what I'm saying?
They just need to get stupid.
Harpercollins don't get creative.
You weird white people never alone.
They just think it's cool.
They just wanna be able to call your rabbit rabbit this story.
Miss Pat,
I don't like the name.
You know what?
If you call me rabbit then you know me.
You know you call me Ms Pat and then you a fan.
I go home,
I'm paying.
But if you call me rabbit,
you know my fucking path and it creeps me out.
I was like,
don't fucking call me rabbit.
So do you say that your family don't call you around?
I tried to tell him,
but I ain't think they know my real fucking,
my brother called me what you're doing right motherfucker.
I'm pat now.
Cause you know I got a brother named Anthony and Tony.
Right?
So I'd be like,
do I call?
Do I call you and call you?
Don't I call you ain't bitch do.
I mean I call him Anthony.
I don't call him anymore.
You just call him and yeah,
we just call him ant.
But that's short for Anthony.
That makes sense.
What?
I call him Anthony and I tell him to call me pat.
Pat.
But he won't.
He won't motherfucker.
And I'm my brother Tony.
My brother Tony,
he's real,
real black.
So we used to call him itchy.
I don't call you itchy bitch.
Don't call me red.
Why did you call him itchy?
Because he was a real blow.
I don't know.
Cause he always looked like you needed lunch.
What are you doing over there?
Answering emails look like you needed to be stretched.
He always looked dry and my sister nickname was may.
Pop May pop.
Yeah.
Why may pop?
I don't fucking know Joe.
Well,
we got the names from Papa's flower.
It's a state flower.
Somewhere I may pop is a flower bouquet.
That's how I learned it may pop,
may pop,
may pop flower.
Is that a flower?
A and I don't know.
I seen it somewhere.
I might be wrong.
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
It's purple,
purple passion flower.
I have no idea why they,
maybe they thought she was a flight.
She was really pretty before.
Crack passive flora in Karnataka.
Yeah.
That's beautiful.
I know my Mama didn't read this shit.
A commonly known as maypops Purple Passion Flower.
The Passion Flower Wild
and a wild passion vine.
A fast growing perineal vine.
Well,
it's beautiful flower though.
If you want to call somebody something like that.
I mean that's a nice thing.
It was crazy because it's wide open,
so that's replicating.
Then replicate her legs.
Her legs were always wide open
there.
She,
yeah,
but her name was may pop.
And I have a brother is named George.
We called him Beau.
Beau.
Yeah,
he's biracial.
He's really biracial.
But my Mama said we all got the same daddy ain't no fucking way when his main
black is fucking cooter brown.
So how Beau is a biracial,
he looked like he's white.
He looks like he's one fuck Yale.
He's,
yeah,
he looked like he white.
But your mother says it comes from something.
Dot.
Yes.
And he's a junior.
So I was like,
I know what day to beat y'all.
Who had a fuck.
Cause when I gave writer,
when I gained a writer,
my brother's and sister's pictures so she can kind of visualize what I'm talking
about.
She was like,
who is this little white girl?
I was like,
that's my oldest brother.
Wow.
She thought he was a little white girl.
Jesus.
Yeah.
But he's black.
I mean,
but I don't know what he is.
We don't talk about it.
What's he in jail for?
A Dui.
Portfo yeah,
he been in jail all his life.
All of us
may pop.
Just got out of jail.
For what?
Uh,
what did may,
oh,
she ran over to crack here.
Me and my,
I told you that she backed up over too many times and they gave her two years
transvestite.
My cousin,
transvestite girlfriend.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I forgot about she's done.
She's out now.
For those who haven't heard that story,
refer to podcast number one.
Yeah,
it was bad.
So she's out now.
She's out now.
Yeah.
She's uh,
in a drug program.
She's getting her tokens day by day,
I guess.
I don't know.
Now when they see you being successful and becoming famous and doing really
well,
and they go to see you at a comedy club,
it's 300 white people laughing and having a great time.
They happy for you,
like,
uh,
you know,
I don't think they,
I don't really think they,
they,
they come,
they got it yet,
you know,
they still think,
oh,
just out here,
you know,
open Mike.
And I don't think they know what I'm exactly doing because I'm not on TV.
So if you ain't on TV to black people,
you ain't made it.
But you're on Ari fear show.
Oh,
it's comedy central show.
That's going to be a,
I think it's this Thursday.
No,
it's next week.
They changed.
No,
they changed.
My sustainer wasn't no fucking comedy.
Saint Jo and I watch comedy central even though you're on it.
No.
Why not?
Uh,
she probably ain't got k before.
First of all,
she just asked me for $20 and pay her rent.
So got cable.
I don't know.
Hmm.
I'm a call.
I need to call and say,
Hey,
you got comedy central.
You,
you should watch me should have a viewing party for your friends back in India.
Family.
You don't have them over.
Your family's not in Indianapolis is not in Atlanta.
So you don't want to have him fly out just to,
uh,
who got their cat of money.
They ain't never been on no plane.
They've never been on a plane no less.
Wow.
They'd been on a bus going to court.
They ain't never been on a plane.
I didn't start flying until I,
um,
became a comedian.
Really?
How old were you the first time he got on an airplane?
What I've been doing this what?
Let them 12 years.
Late twenties.
Wow.
So the first time you got an airplane,
we shit in your pants.
I had somebody to go with me.
I had a friend who worked at the airline and you know,
my mom,
just people,
black people scared to fly.
That is so fucking true.
We were other drive 25 hours to get on the plane.
Honestly,
you might think I'm allowing my granddad and married this lady who has some
money and she said,
your grandfather,
my grandfather,
he's dead now.
He married this lady who has some money and he did.
She wanted to go on a honeymoon.
He was like,
I don't want to go on a fucking plane and his man,
and he's 68 so she talked to him.
I want to get on a plane.
He came back and divorce that bitch.
He said,
I told that bitch I didn't want to fly.
Why?
He came back from the honeymoon and they never lived together.
Just because she made him fly.
She made him fly.
Wow.
So I was always scared.
My mom was like,
we don't get on a fucking plane.
It ain't for us.
What was the Gig?
White people are better than you.
Don't get on a plane.
She was saying white people,
only white people fly.
Y'All like dying in the air when you smoke,
when you light my cigarette,
this is how you make my drink.
This is how you keep a wall in your back pocket.
Basically everything your mother told you was wrong.
Did she ever give you any good advice?
Uh,
no.
No,
no,
she did.
She didn't know.
I don't have any fault.
You know what I said my mama did the best she could because she could have been
like these new bitches of the day and just dropped us off and kept going.
You know,
these whole leaving the babies at the mall,
she struggled with her five kids.
I think I,
you know,
she was,
she gave us what she was handed down.
Right.
And until somebody tap you on the shoulder,
say,
hey,
it's different shit out here.
Let's try something different like my husband did with me,
then you don't know.
I mean I got cousins who live in just like my Mama,
all these different,
I mean all of these kids and welfare and no job.
It just,
it's,
it just keeps being handed down.
Criminal activity,
going to jail,
you know,
date.
Like my brother got two kids and I follow them on Instagram.
Right.
And they always in the hood,
got all my friends joy.
I'm fresh in this bitch.
And I said,
look at these stupid motherfuckers.
Look at these stupid motherfucker.
I'm about to go wait in line for tennis shoes.
Really?
Motherfucker.
But that's it.
That's all they know in their atmosphere.
Yeah.
I mean
that's what you,
you saw and you became the same,
but your children are seeing something different.
I mean,
that's what's really fascinating,
especially as you become successful.
You're children are seeing a you that's learned and grown.
And as we've talked about this last time you were on here,
the conversations that you had with your daughter,
when you kind of,
you know,
you've let your daughter know like,
look,
this is me.
I was very young when I had you.
And I've learned some things and along the way I've become a better person in a
different person and you're a different person,
a better person than I was when I was your age.
You know?
And it's like this information that you're picking up,
you're,
you're spreading your kids,
you,
you broke the chain,
you know,
you've broken the cycle.
That's kind to be very happy for you.
One of the concerns I had was dropouts.
Nobody graduated.
Like I dropped out in eighth and my sister dropped out and mom and him,
everybody going to jail and teenage pregnancy.
I said to myself,
you motherfuckers would not be fucking my baby at 14 I don't know who
motherfuckers I was talking about,
but I'm just talking about in general.
Right.
Well she ended up being gay so she could have used a little dick
that she's gay by nature or
uh,
I don't know cause she said she was born gay.
I said not according to the ultrasound.
The ultrasound says whether you're gay or not.
She wasn't sucking no.
Mean when she was in my stomach.
So I don't know where she get that had been from,
not a court.
I don't know.
She say she was born that away.
Don't trust her.
I mean if she says that,
if she said
now,
I think,
I think also that my daughter did not have a good example of what a man should
have been because she always saw her daddy beat me.
She was there when her daddy shot me.
She was dealt with all of the abuse,
all the way,
half of the bitches.
I caught him cheating with my daughter,
took me to the house.
Right.
So her,
her vision of a man at that time was like,
she was like,
I don't like boys.
I can remember her as a little girl saying,
I don't like boys because they hit you.
Mm.
Well,
that there is that,
um,
the,
that that is a factor for sure.
That women that have been abused,
that have turned to gay relationships.
There's women that weren't gay when they were young or didn't think they were
gay when they're young.
They were,
they were involved in Male,
female relationships,
but they got,
they encountered so many assholes that they just wanted love.
And it's more acceptable for a woman to become gay too than a man to become gay.
For a guy to become gay.
It's very difficult for straight.
Yeah.
Can't go back.
No,
we can't go back.
Yeah.
You know,
I as pop,
they see it.
Yeah.
No Man cares if a woman has lesbian relationships,
it's nice.
It's like you took a break from deck.
It's like you're a virgin reborn,
you know,
men don't mind.
They think it's hot.
Well my daughter,
she's not,
she doesn't do that,
you know,
switching back and forth.
She's just strictly,
I always have been,
I mean I can remember we thought it noticing like I said around middle school,
my eye,
we went over my super saved mother-in-law house.
She,
she talks me her safe.
She's super safe.
I should do is pray and this is what she told my husband.
She said Y'all need to pray for this girl.
She got a gay spirit.
Oh my.
Cause me and my mother in law at the time wasn't really tight so I was like fuck
her and we need to pray for a whole week cause he's dried out.
But she had a gay spirit.
That's what she told my husband.
She didn't tell me that cause I would,
I probably would've cussed her ass out old was your daughter when my daughter
was probably nine,
when she was nine or 10,
we t we was over my mother in law house and when I got home my husband said,
my mother said Ashley has a gay spirit on her.
But if you asked Ashley,
she said she'd been gay since elementary.
I mean she said she knew when she really started liking girls and elementary.
Well,
it,
what's interesting is that you
variances,
same sort of thing that she experienced when meaning that your mother was abused
by your father and uh,
she,
you saw violence and you saw a young pregnancy and all that stuff,
but her reaction was very different than your reaction.
You love men.
Yeah.
I've never been with a woman,
so I tend to think she's probably,
it's probably a little bit of both.
You know,
she was probably born,
I mean obviously people are born gay,
right?
I would,
I got assume I got some gay neighbors.
I can't imagine these dudes with a check.
They're gay.
They're gay as fuck.
They've always come.
I've seen little kids,
they act like they,
you know,
I do believe that people can be born gay
healing the split.
I like,
I got a nephew,
I got a nephew and his song hit us play
like he was a fucking girl and I was like,
oh my God,
everybody is gay.
Whoa.
Hold on.
Maybe just like John Claude van Damme movies.
Let's throw some kicks.
No,
no,
he was in a split,
like a cheerleader cheering.
Tada.
Use by five.
But I have a nephew and I notice gate.
Okay.
And he called me like when he was younger,
I think he's about probably probably 12 now,
but he called me one day.
He started looking gay real young to me,
but he called me real young.
Like how,
how was that about seven he just had those Tennessee and his mama would say your
brother,
because he's my brother's son.
Your brother need to be around my son because he liked my shoes and he liked my
clothing,
like my weeds.
So you kind of ignore it as just a boy and you know,
trying to find herself.
But my nephew called me a couple of years back and he's like,
cause he think I'm famous.
And he was an Unti.
Do you?
Uh,
I'm singing,
I'm in a singing group.
I said,
Oh really?
So you know you're thinking it's a black kid.
He rnb singer or a rapper.
So I saw what you singing babies?
My,
Oh my,
me and my group be singing all the single ladies.
What the fuck?
I said he seems to be us say songs and Rihanna song and he'd be sitting me gas.
Very helpful was I be telling him he's 14.
He fight a lot because my brother just told me fight a lot at school because
kids mess with him at school a lot.
But so I think he's gay.
I just think,
you know,
I think he's gay,
but you don't know he's gay.
So he needs,
once he find himself and and,
and not worry about what other people think of him,
then he'll come out to be gay.
Like I got a lot of gay people in my family.
Interesting.
It sounds like he's gay.
I think he's gay.
He's it.
All the single ladies and can dance.
He can twerk like a pussy and between his leg.
Oh you are?
I'm telling you my nephew can cut a road block.
A girl cuts a rug cut around.
That's an expression you don't hear anymore.
No,
Kinda rough.
Cut a road.
I was like,
Lord have mercy.
This isn't Glarus all though.
Right?
Stretching,
stretching.
No.
See I could do a split.
Oh Shit just made me gay.
No,
I'm just making a gay that.
Look man,
that ain't what my nuts man.
My nephew said on his balls on his balls.
You know how girl hit is splitting off of John and write down the flow you got
Jessie just prayed like this is my nephew said
this is a little kid that used to live in my neighborhood who was gay as fuck
and he was only like five years old and his mother was trying to get them into
football.
It was hilarious.
Like they were trying to get them to do manly stuff and he just wanted to play
with dolls and you just want to play with girls.
And He,
like his mother was talking to my wife,
you know,
and trying to like figure out a way,
like I just want to get them to get enough football.
I just think that if he's around more men and like,
I'm like,
oh no,
like she's in denial.
Like she doesn't want a gay son.
It just like,
she,
you could tell she was like resisting this.
It was upsetting her and it was almost like she was like reaching out to try to
get someone to say,
yeah,
if you just get them into football,
it's just a,
that'll fix him.
Yeah.
He'll just turn straight.
Meanwhile,
he was like,
I love you until I,
it's can I play with you?
Like he was gay and he's a little gay guy,
you know,
she just,
she didn't want to accept it.
Yeah.
It's weird.
Oh,
he's,
he's born like that.
Yeah,
definitely.
I mean,
there was a study they did in Rome,
some,
some Italian University,
um,
where they,
they believe that with gay men that it's a variation of the x chromosome because
they found that women who were promiscuous,
like ultra promiscuous,
had greater instances of homosexual male sons.
And so that they thought
what they thought was that it's possible that some women,
like some people are just hyper sexual.
Like there's,
there's different levels just like this,
different levels of intelligence and different levels of,
you know,
some people have great singing voices,
some people would just,
they,
sex feels better to them.
They're more attracted to it.
They want it all the time.
It's,
some girls could not be with one man.
And when they found women who are just almost like a chronically promiscuous
and,
uh,
not just promiscuous,
but,
uh,
we're,
we would cheat on their husbands,
cheat on their boyfriends and just fucked everybody.
They could.
Those women had a greater instance of having gay sons and they felt like this is
probably like there's a genetic,
so they liked the most deep it get passed down to the sun like in,
Yup.
Yeah,
that it literally passed down through my nephew,
mom and acts like a lot of variety
because my nephew,
he be sending me video,
I was like Lord have mercy,
the videos a day and they were a w uh,
with my kids.
And you know my son,
I have a 14 year old son.
So at the time they just been my three,
four years ago and so I got them there cause you know,
kind of get them to bond because they cousin,
they don't get to see each other.
So my son come back,
sorry Mama,
what's wrong with him?
I said,
well what do you mean he didn't want to sit there and let the water hit his
balls,
his water,
his boss,
what water?
You know,
they would go down in their walk down pool.
[inaudible]
would just set up and let the water hit him with
my kid and my son was gay.
I said,
shut the fuck up.
He ain't gay and now look,
he was right.
I mean he haven't came out yet.
You Not Ganti you say
me.
My daughter was not gay until she told me over the phone.
We assume she was gay,
but she was gay.
Before that you just did.
She went to college just to eat pussy.
She went to college and lost her fucking mind.
Justi pussy or she read a couple of books.
I think her major was eating pussy.
She,
she lost her mind in college.
More accepting of a girl,
daughter,
a daughter being gay or a son being gay.
Like if you think about your girl eating pussy,
you know,
I'm sure it's kind of,
it takes a while to get used to.
But is that the same as your son taken it in the ass?
Yeah,
I would think that that would be,
I would think that would be a on the hierarchy.
Key of a sexual acceptance.
More difficulty.
I don't know.
Dell,
I'm glad my daughter's not disturbed in the relationship.
Right.
And she's the woman,
she's the woman.
What is her,
her girlfriend like?
Ah,
butch.
Jeb Bush cheeks with uh,
with the,
she was dating a white cheek.
She just dumped her.
I liked her.
Oh my God.
I liked this white girl,
but she,
my daughter home,
I told my daughter,
I said,
I'm so glad you gay because of you took as much decreased as you eat much pussy
you will be wore out,
wore out,
wore out.
It wouldn't be nothing in writing.
No,
she just,
she is a whore.
Oh,
how dare I not like that.
I mean she liked,
she liked,
I think she just got to switch them up too much.
Switch them up tomorrow.
Yes.
I'm tired of this.
How it's time to go on until the next one.
And she'd never say they're my girlfriend.
She say these are my friends.
So what do people say when they like a lot of six?
They,
everybody's their friends.
That's what people say when they were like a lot of sex.
I think so clean.
Never heard that before.
I've never heard that before.
Zeroes are guys from girls,
you know,
they didn't give you,
hey,
you show up,
but this,
when you see somebody with different people all the time and then they have like
maybe six month relationship in three months relationship and then you look up
and they with somebody else.
To me that's a person that's a greedy ass person.
Hmm.
I haven't known this done.
You know one thing that you guys do notice is when girls don't have any
girlfriends is when they're only have a bunch of men friends through our girls
are just have girlfriends and to a gal.
Every one of those girls that I've ever met that just has male friends and just
do
everybody,
don't fuck.
Don't on the sneak temp on the needs.
We go play tennis.
Yeah.
Fucking fuck it in the car.
Everywhere.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
I wouldn't know.
I don't do stuff like that.
I understand my,
I,
I wasn't going to treat my vagina like that.
All right.
I already started early.
That was a lot of stress down.
I shouldn't say to a girl because I do know some girls.
I should take that back.
They'll sleep with their girlfriends.
It is so popular.
Yeah.
They don't give a fuck.
They have a relationship with our girlfriend said we just got high and try
something new.
I'd like to hit each other on the aids.
Like when my daughter was in high school,
all the girls would hit each other on the ass and I'm like,
well y'all get up.
You don't.
You don't wait a minute.
Hit you say hit each other on the ass.
Yeah.
You don't like they titties hit they titties.
They bumped titties.
Really?
Going on.
Where you come from Joe.
You don't have teenage kids grew up in Boston.
Oh,
I was too cold.
Teddy bumping.
Well especially
well,
yeah,
they do all count.
All freaky stuff with each other.
Yeah,
that kiss,
that girlfriend.
I never thought about doing shit like that.
It wasn't going on when I was a kid.
It's pouring,
man.
It's so popular now because
even when I'm a girl,
I still won't get dressed in front of my girlfriend.
What made you,
I'm going in his bathroom and fill up.
My pain is over.
They don't get fucked over.
What is it?
A pancake or a panic.
You cooking a burger and she was done on the other side.
You turn them over inside out
giving you a busy,
that's not a good visual.
Don't give a fuck what they do these days.
They don't give a fuck.
I think Brian's right.
I think it's a porn thing because the,
the shaving of the vaginas when I was in high school didn't exist.
Girls or jungles down there and now every,
not that I know.
High school girls pussies these days.
You probably right,
but I would think that women today,
like the reason why they trim,
I'm like that it's directly to porn and like they will have sex now when,
when even when I was starting young,
if you gave it up,
you wanted a relationship.
They don't,
they don't give a fuck.
You can have sex with me and I never got to speak to me again.
I just wanted to try it out.
Like it's a fucking ice cream and if you didn't like it,
just throw it away.
Wait a minute.
There was a lot of girls that used to fuck and didn't want it.
Relationships though.
That's not where I come from.
Indianapolis.
No,
I'm from Atlanta.
Atlanta.
When girls would have sex with a man,
they wanted a relationship.
My neighborhood.
Yeah,
they you live that was a boyfriend.
It wasn't just no random dude.
You know you would say that little light.
Are you going to do you want to be my girlfriend?
Check yes or no?
Yes.
So that's what I told my baby daddy.
Even though he was 22 man,
I wanted a relationship and you know,
you give it up,
you want it to be special.
Now they just have sex and they don't,
they don't give a fuck.
I grew up where we had like girls that just wanted to fuck and they looked like
there was like a sewer behind her apartment and all like the popular kids would
go down there and they'll go inside this sewer and fuck him in the center.
Sue and that would just like line up pretty much just
tried drain ditch for water.
It's not sewer.
Sewer is where you,
your shit water rain was like when these huge tubes and just emptied out into
this big field but it never had anything in there so it would go way back in
there and somebody put a couch back there at one point.
Oh and this was like,
oh so you never had sex outside?
Yo Yo whatever now.
Okay.
Not In the sewer.
Well my kid's side was Mary Woods is normal.
He didn't have no fucking money.
So we did it out of time in the graveyard graveyard.
Really Nice.
Nobody there.
They just looking.
I used to run in graveyards,
do my road work cause I would remind me that I was going to be dead someday.
I was going to be under this ground.
This is not having any regrets that that's not true.
You can tell them to cook you and you just be floating in the ocean.
That's not what I mean.
I mean being around coach you and you'll be floating in the ocean.
Just being around cemeteries,
like remind you that this is a temporary thing that one day,
you know,
you lead to be dead in the ocean,
float around or they will each in the ocean or you'll be buried either way.
The idea was that on top,
because I can't breathe down now I'm claustrophobic,
so I want you to bear meal top of the ground.
Oh.
Like they do in New Orleans,
they have those,
they do them in different places if you pay for them,
well they do it in a lot of places where they have problems with the ground
being underwater.
Like um,
what did they called the crips,
you know,
I have no idea.
Yeah,
yeah,
they,
they make those things at a cement and they build them up.
So you're all,
everything's above ground.
When my mama passed away,
I was 16 so I would go to a grave sometime.
So my boyfriend bought her a little tombstone and stuff and I go out there and
when they were my celiacs and she got an ant pile on top of her or her
tombstone,
I go to my car,
get gas set at home.
You set the Ann Hill on fire cause it was on your mother's tombstone and I was
trying to get rid of the ads,
set it on fire.
You got to,
so everybody's shit out there burning.
I'm about to get a raise.
So you were pouring gasoline ant pile?
He was here and I just couldn't,
I wasn't thinking I was young and didn't answer it on the stone.
Hawes was flat
like that and so they had built up this big ass pile like well you on top,
well not on top.
So you know it was on there and I wanted to get it off.
I caught myself cleaning or gray and I go to my car,
get just a little gasoline set.
That bitch.
I'm like Ooh.
And her boyfriend is buried next to him.
So he burner,
she burned,
her boyfriend was buried right next to her boyfriend.
Was He bought,
he bought the plot next door.
When did he go?
I don't know.
Cause after she died,
you know,
she just went to sleep and never woke up.
It ain't,
she wasn't sick.
I remember talking to her the week that she died because she said come over here
and I was selling drugs.
So she was like,
Ray,
man,
I need you to come over here and pay my light.
Bill.
Mom called you rabbit.
Yeah,
I remember going to the clinic with my Mama one day and she,
my Mama,
you know,
she was illiterate.
She couldn't read.
I love a rest or so,
but she couldn't spell our names.
So she said rabbit,
how to spell your real name.
And so this kid overheard her and say,
Yo Momma dog.
She can't spell your name.
My mom say,
shut up bitch.
You all know me.
I dropped out in eighth grade but I was on the ninth grade level.
So I'm standing there like,
why the fuck did you say that?
That's stupid.
But because she was in eighth grade and ninth grade level,
probably dropped out in the Er.
I don't know when she dropped out,
but she dropped out.
Wow.
Your mom,
Connie Robin's dark.
Why?
Cause it's your quick selling name.
Well it wasn't my crack selling named Dan.
That was my nickname.
Oh.
And to my crack dealer night.
Oh,
so because you can't go on the street name,
your real name.
Everybody know pooky black May,
may,
may Ma,
you know,
you know the shit.
They call us in the head.
Everybody got those films.
You watched those films.
Boyz in the hood and thanks everybody got a nickname.
So how did you get rapid than if it wasn't a crack dealer named?
What did rabbit,
I don't know.
They say I like carrots,
raw carrots when I was little,
but I've always been called rabbit.
Wow.
So it was like before you can remember you were rabid.
Yeah.
Wow.
We had a kid and cool.
It's cool to call them onion.
Did you have any idea?
Did you have a nickname,
Joe?
Growing up for anything?
A nickname?
Nobody.
Your Momma didn't give anybody a nickname for keys and only one of them got a
nickname only because he's a junior.
He knows the sad shit when people give themselves a nickname,
get the fuck out of here with that.
Well that's what I want you to guys to start calling me the turbo.
That's like strippers.
They get a set of nicknames.
Yeah,
but that's like a stage name.
You know,
it touches.
So Dude's can't be creeping
on you.
I had the worst name,
but people called me poof because my hair was so big.
Like I had like the uh,
what was popular in that show?
The,
with a 21 jump street?
No.
And the other one,
uh,
with uh,
Dylan McKay or what's his name?
Yeah.
I used to have this kind of thing going on,
so I wanted to do a quick poof and it took me a while to get used to.
How long did that nicknames took from like a high school to win?
Sort of five years.
You had poof.
And then like once in a while somebody will run into me that from my old days
and be like,
poof,
and I'm like,
oh,
he's really don't have nicknames.
So they'd given their self neat name to be super
cool.
No.
Why kids have nicknames.
It was a lot of white kids would nicknames just not as popular as black.
So yeah,
there's a lot of them.
Yeah.
We,
I know a lot of white kids who have nicknames.
Yeah.
When I was a kid,
when I lived in Newton,
there was this part of Newton,
it's still exists called the Lake Newton north where everybody calls everybody
mush and it stuck.
It's one part of the country.
This one part of the city.
This is one part of this one small suburb where everybody's like Mush,
Mush.
We've got to go down this fucking thing,
We've got to get this fucking guy mush.
We've got to go to this movie mush.
It's going to go get something to eat mush.
Is it based off the militia mouth?
Nope.
It's like,
dude,
it's like if their version of dude,
it's not even insulting.
Yeah.
It still exists.
To this day
my family say but doe but doe is not a word.
I don't know what it is and I didn't even realize it until my husband called it.
My husband catch a lot of shit listening to me like use it and what?
What your like you know but don't over that.
But they'll come on but don't let's do this.
But doe the doe but Dow,
my whole family's say but dow so either talking about a person like calling you
but doe doe but they're saying but doh like to you like you're a widow.
Yeah we're going to do a podcast but doe yeah,
that's how we talk.
We all talk like damn.
I was like,
why do y'all say but dough?
And I was like,
we don't say but though.
And he's like,
yes you do say but doubt you didn't realize you were saying it and you still
sad.
I do say Buddo.
Do you ever say it on stage?
This it slip out?
No,
I said with my family a lot,
you know,
cause you don't want to go back and your family,
thank you.
Bougie.
Never listen to someone say,
you know,
so many fucking times you want to strangle him.
I've been listening to podcasts lately and like,
and you know,
like there's some people that don't understand.
I mean I've,
I've been guilty of it myself,
but when you listen to it,
you realize it.
Cause it's a way of saying,
ah,
like some people say fucking this fucking guy with his fucking,
and what they're really saying is this,
um,
guy with his,
but they don't want to say,
um,
so they'll say this is fucking,
or they'll say like,
you know,
it's like,
you know this like,
you know,
and you're like,
oh my fucking God,
please stop saying that shit.
Yeah.
Comedians,
they that alive.
They think it no state.
Well,
sometimes it works.
Like sometimes there's actually,
there's a reason to do it.
Like you're setting something
up or you're allowing the audience to think along,
like out the every joke,
uh,
like,
he's like,
damn motherfucker,
then you rehearse today,
Huh?
Fuck.
Do you rehearse your material?
Yes you do.
Well,
you know I've been shot at a couple of times so I need to get it going and
not like in the mirror.
I'm gone.
I'm saying this
as some bull shit there.
I hate that shit.
Cause when I first started I was like,
you gotta talk to you see yourself in the mirror.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you talking about to talk to yourself in the fucking comedians
who don't know shit about coming?
Yo just rehearsing.
You go on stage,
you sound like a fucking,
you giving a speech.
And I was like,
I sat on a robotic,
I don't want to do this bull shit.
So I just started,
you know,
stopped at rehearsing and shit.
I go over my set but I'm not going to go in the mirror and said Andy and I said
this and then I was shot two time and dope nine I'll do that.
Bullshit.
You write down all the different things you want to talk about because my mind
is always going and I'm on work.
I'm always remembering shit from my past and so much going on in my purse.
You know you're coming so you definitely get a premise every day.
So I mean,
you know,
most of us do now.
Do you worry that you're going to eventually run out of stories about your life?
I'm going to run out of star.
I can't fucking wait to stop telling these stories to move on.
It's cause it's gonna be challenging right now.
I'm,
I'm blessed with so much to talk about.
You know,
a lot of companies don't have that opportune.
I see white boys ain't did shit.
They Mama fucking cat jokes in dog jokes
and I was like shut the fuck up and go rob a liquor store so you can talk about
something.
Yeah,
you fucking blessed fucker fucker.
Go Rob a liquor store.
But yeah,
I mean we all,
me prior Mi prior started off with his whole life and eventually he moved on to
shit in his current light.
You know,
I have a current life.
A lot of the Shit I talk about now is from my past,
but I still have a current life.
I mean that I haven't even really gotten to,
I could probably do it well.
We're working on an hour now.
That's not even getting,
only going to show just a small portion of my current life.
You're going to uh,
put together a comedy special show.
I'm working on it.
I hope so.
Yeah.
What do you a or would you have a timeline?
We try to do it like,
well,
I'm talking to her.
Oh,
I'm talking to my managers,
so we back and forth trying to get it together first.
Or You,
have you filmed anything?
If you're like,
no,
nothing yet.
Sometimes it's good to just do a set somewhere,
film it and then just go over and say,
I can expand on this.
I could,
do you watch yourself?
Yes.
More.
The manager that I have forces me to watch and listen to myself.
I never did it before,
but it helps because you know I'm from the south.
I can't talk with she.
I fuck up some words and why people stay.
What did you say?
Yeah,
but it's good.
Like when you,
when you fuck up words,
it's like,
it's fun.
It's like say like when I first moved from Georgia and then I had this joke
about my was like my mom would say,
set your hot car cas down cock cock hot cock cock is a Dick,
right?
But all these years,
my mom's been telling me to sit,
my hot decay is down.
So when I was doing a joke in the Midwest and I said hot cock and everybody
like,
what the fuck you gotta Caulk?
But
your mother used to say,
set your heart cock parents say said,
hey,
such a hot Caucasians down.
Wait a minute.
I guarantee you all black parents do not say down south.
They do down south hot cock and I can call my brother Retina.
He hard cock ass down.
I guarantee you I'm not going to find shit.
Set your hot car
gas down.
Hot Cock Bass down.
Ms Pat,
first person that comes up.
Mm.
Nope.
Darkness.
[inaudible] first thing,
first thing you find is a Craig's list ad for Phoenix.
Cock sucker wants to deep rim your ripe and that's a sort of first my brother
for you.
You didn't know you wanted cock transsexuals,
bareback city eight.
These are,
this is the,
uh,
keep that noise down your cock up.
Come down my throat.
You just free porn movies.
Did you?
Okay.
Yeah.
There's nothing,
nothing cock has down.
Hmm.
Nope.
Southern hot coffee.
No,
I'm calling my brother for you.
So go ahead.
I believe I'm not,
it's not that I don't believe you.
It's just really funny.
You want to talk to him?
Cock.
That's what a farm.
He's probably still a fucking up somebody to transmission and was a transmission
specialists.
No,
he's,
he's a fake ass mechanic.
A fake.
What is a fake mechanic who tell you he knew so he doesn't really know what he's
doing.
Oh,
hey.
It got him back.
He'd say he fixed costs.
We're really don't.
I mean,
he ain't went to school for it.
He just be trying some shit.
So he just fucks around.
He fixed my car.
One time I had a,
um,
I had a SUV.
I'm on tear route,
so I needed a head job.
So he told me what the spark plugs kept jumping out the engine.
So that jumped out of it.
You know,
they kept coming out cause they needed,
he has stripped to up the hairs on my car.
So instead of saying,
Hey,
I fucked up here,
your heads,
you know,
you need to get ahead job.
This boy went on my back porch,
got my Bible,
Q spatular broke that bitch,
I'll stick it in the engine and screwed that gasket back down.
So I was like,
the cost still running ragged it.
fuck you,
you taught my $300 I go to the dirty shit dog.
She took a barbecue,
bachelor attached to yours.
You're lucky it didn't explode.
He say,
look,
I pull up to the dealer shield.
I'm not lying.
And the man take the thing and he said,
ma'am,
who put a barbecue spatula,
your engine?
I that motherfucker
charge you $300 to put a barbecue spatula barbecues,
bachelor.
That costs me $20 you know what,
I'm real long
fire.
Yes.
He broke.
That bitch is stuck it in my engine is ridiculous.
And I was like,
why didn't you do that mother fucker?
He was like,
I was trying to keep your spark plugs in your engine.
Then how did he learn anywhere?
Did he go to school?
He's getting better.
No more specialist.
He's at the point where you can trust them.
What an oil change and oil change.
I will trust my daughter with an oil change.
No,
just him.
Cause he hard
courts.
This is where they go to.
How fucking hard is that?
Yeah.
Boy He is horrible.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
He's learning.
He's,
I mean his hand hold training.
Where does he do it all in and wound.
He got a mobile business,
mobile business.
As soon as he fuck up your car,
he changed his number.
Oh no he doesn't.
Does he really?
I got three Anthony's in here
fucking hilarious.
So he just fucks up people's cars,
changes his number and just gets ghost get goals.
Do you feel mate?
He told one lady,
one lady,
one lady told him,
she said,
Anthony,
you lied to me.
You said you were going to Redo my car.
My brother said,
look,
you're a bitch.
One thing I don't do is I don't lie.
What I did was not tell you the truth.
He said,
she said,
bitch you,
that's still alive.
He is hilarious.
What I do is not tell you the truth,
but he said he don't lie.
What's the difference?
Nothing.
How did we start this mobile business of fixing people's cars and we all got
busy and we can't work nowhere.
So he just started working on people's cars and just start bullshitting and
figured it out along the way.
Yes.
What?
My stepfather was a mechanic and so all my brothers like him and my brother,
my brother and my brother and Tony,
they do mechanic work together.
Right?
I mean,
so they just go out and fuck up people calls.
But he's,
he fired Tony.
Tony gets social security now.
So he fired Tony.
So it just,
him by himself be fired him because he gets social security can be a part of the
team.
He said,
Tony,
you know,
so security would only let you put in 20 hours.
40 cut.
You check.
Oh,
I don't know why he fired Tony.
They fight all the fucking time.
So he's just had to be a lone wolf out there fixing cars.
Changed your phone numbers,
put a fucking spatulate in your engine.
That is hilarious.
And then I got it running.
Get you say you want it,
run it.
Yeah.
Motherfucker but not make it to the stop
sign.
Yeah.
Not with a broken spatula.
It'll poke his badge.
I took that.
She took dealership,
they white dude could not stop laughing.
And I'm like,
well you laughing.
But that's my good 15,
$20 bachelor and I'm out of $300 for a head job.
I thought I got.
Wow.
So he never gave you the money back?
Hell No.
He got six kids.
He got a set of triplets and then he has a,
um,
he has a few more outside kids from his wife,
outside kids
outside kids.
They was keys and can live in his house.
Oh,
they don't live with him.
Wow.
God Damn.
That is crazy.
My family is crazy.
You should go.
You just go all and ms pet family towards bad.
I think what's going to happen next.
Okay.
What's already happened is you got a book deal.
What's going to happen next is you're going to have a fucking reality show.
Reality Show.
Why not?
I want a real show.
I mean,
what does that mean?
You know,
like,
I mean I don't,
I ain't going to say I don't want a reality show,
but
you want a real show like you want to Darren Mack Bernays.
Rosie.
Right,
I understand.
That makes sense.
And you would be great at that.
However,
what's really hilarious is the true stories.
And if you want me to put them people on TV,
Joe,
who don't tame that Shit,
you don't have to tame it.
What I'm saying is the difference between,
like if somebody gets a hold of your life and start turning into a sitcom
script,
they're not going to do it justice.
They're just not.
Especially get a bunch of white writers.
It's cable.
They really gonna be able to capture it.
Yeah,
but that's different.
The wires,
all fiction,
you know?
No,
it's not.
I live that boy shit.
I don't know what you talking about.
Not,
I mean,
it's never happens.
I'm like,
someone wrote all those characters because he was a guy that was a reporter in
that neighborhood.
That's how that came about.
Go Google it.
What do you mean?
Who was a reporter who wrote the book?
He was,
yeah,
he was like a reporter.
Like he would go out with the police and stuff when all of that stuff was
happening and he just says,
this was what I heard from my writer.
He just started to capture that stuff and ended up writing a book.
Well,
I may,
I believe that,
but a lot of that stuff really went on in DC.
I'm sure it did.
But the words that they put in the mouse was all created by writers and
calculated and written out.
Have you read it?
If you write stuff about,
if you wrote it,
if you wrote a movie about my past,
I mean,
you know,
of course you're going to have to,
kind of torque everything,
but a lot of work,
tweak,
tweak or whatever you call it,
a Torque,
you know.
But a lot of it would be missing
pad.
Right.
I believe you,
but no better way to show the real people.
Well,
kind to show the real people.
What do you mean looking like what?
Come on a bunch of black people can't talk.
Fighting over a car game.
Be hilarious.
Yeah,
for a little while,
but it wouldn't be hilarious.
Here come air shop.
No.
And uh,
what is it?
The other bloggers,
Sharpton,
Jesse Jackson and all the other ones.
This is not high.
I don't know.
He out his shit from now.
Then you don't have to listen to them talk.
They don't help you.
They will not help you.
You get to talk shit about them after they start talking.
I talk shit about them now.
But you can be talking shit even stronger if they give you a hard time about
your show.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Oh,
believe me.
Well,
I'm not telling you what to do.
I mean you do whatever you want to do.
I'm not going to say I would take anything because I can't,
I can't see me being the silly fat chick I,
that's not a role for me.
You see,
the thing is you don't need,
the thing about a reality show is you don't need a role.
You can just don't miss paths world and you could narrate it.
You know,
you could stand in front of the camera and go,
we're about to meet my fucking brother Anthony,
who pretends he's a fucking mechanic.
This stupid motherfucker put a fucking spatially inside my head.
You can tell that story and then you can do that crazy family that's on TV now.
That's a lot of show duck dynasty.
No,
not damn Kardashians.
It's a real sick,
calm,
um,
modern family,
modern,
modern family.
I never watched that show.
That's a funny show off the boat.
No,
but that's my friend Eddie Wong Story.
That fucking shit is anyone do.
That shit is hilarious.
He's hilarious.
I had to go to the bathroom after watching that show.
You had to go to the bathroom and pee.
They view okay.
That shit had my stomach working.
I mean,
Russell's,
I was lacking that.
I edit one.
If you ain't got nobody else supporting you,
I watch that shit every week.
My husband record.
I love that show.
It's only two episodes in,
but y'all need to watch fresh off the boat.
Well,
it's based on the story of his life that he wrote and he is the narrator and
there's a little boy who plays him.
The rapper dude.
There was a little boy.
The young boy plays him and then there's Randall Park who's a comedian and
actor.
He actually played Kim Jong wound in the
think he's a rapper.
I didn't,
I haven't seen the show yet,
but it must be him.
Yeah,
it's a little boy.
He talks like a rapper.
Eddie.
Eddie talks like he's from Brooklyn.
He grew up in Orlando is funny.
Your friends show is funny watch.
He's got a great show on vice to his show on vice.
It's called off the boat or fresh off the boat with Eddie Wong.
No,
that's all ABC?
no,
no.
He's got a vice show titles.
The vice is this channel online vice.com and he has a show on vice.
That's him.
You know like he's a cook.
He's a very famous chef.
Okay.
Yeah.
He's a very,
very accomplished chef and that's like what he does for a living.
But he's a hilarious fucking dude is fucking hilarious.
That show.
It's so funny.
And Empire.
I haven't seen it in pie.
It's really good too,
isn't it?
You just sit around watching TV shows,
watch a lot
on your home.
Yeah.
When I'm home I try to catch up
this time when my husband,
you know,
you have to do stuff that you know your partner likes.
So he liked to watch a lot of TV,
especially when his gout flare it up.
So what does he feel?
How does he feel about you or go on the road all the time now because he's like,
you guys been together for awhile and now all of a sudden you're the successful
touring comedian.
He,
um,
he's very,
he's in the beginning.
Joe.
He was not supportive.
He did not think I was funny.
Wow.
No,
he actually said no thank you.
Were funny because he said nobody.
I think it's the way he protect me because I was talking about my life,
you know all,
I got a baby by a married man and his get shot means like,
and a lot of time a lot of those stories come in and he's like,
what's the shoot your wife in the checks?
He was like,
I didn't fucking shoot her.
So he didn't,
he was like,
this stuff is too dark for him.
And he still don't laugh,
but he's supportive.
He tried it every now and then.
Give me something to talk about.
And he helps me out every now and then.
So when he hears you on podcasts and your tones,
colors doesn't listen.
Why not?
I don't know.
He don't come.
He only seen me live one time.
What?
One time.
Wow.
That seems crazy.
He came to Wa,
I used to open for cat Williams.
So who was in Kentucky and it was cat has old,
like 20 something thousand tickets.
And my cat was like,
your husband should come out and see you.
And I was like,
my husband never going to come see me.
He say,
call him up.
I,
I called my husband,
cat got on the phone was like,
I want you to come see your wife.
I pay,
I fly you and the kids.
And he's like,
well,
we live in Kentucky.
He said,
well,
jumping around a card and I pay for it.
And he was like,
you ain't got to do that.
I come.
So he came down there,
20,000 people and Kat,
um,
let me go out second and everybody was doing 15.
He said,
go do 25 for your husband and I fucking killed.
And my kids said the whole time my husband ducking his chill like that,
she'd be funny.
Oh,
And that changed his whole outlook on me.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
Yes.
20,000 for the first time you ever see your wife on stage.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
First time he ever saw you onstage.
20,000 people in the camp.
So strange to him for so long.
Yeah.
Never came.
Never did you crush it?
I crushed it.
Yes I did.
But you did.
So he like,
like he'll watch stuff like,
you know,
I'm about to be on comedy central or affair.
So he probably would record it and watch it when I'm not home watching.
When you're not home,
he doesn't want to be,
he doesn't want you to be around when he's watching it.
I can't watch myself on TV.
Cause then you all,
you're fat,
you're swearing.
Oh look at my neck,
you know [inaudible] sweaty [inaudible] reason.
It was hiding that damn place where we shot at and my ma,
I was sweating my ass off the Strip club.
Yeah,
no cheaters.
So I was fucking hot and I was just looking at the premium.
I was like,
Oh holy fuck,
I'm sweating.
That's hilarious.
So I will it,
what
is it like working with Katt Williams?
He was really nice.
You know,
I can't,
it was 2012 2012 I think.
And the week I got the Gig we cat,
my father had passed that Monday and they call me,
they Wednesday,
Tammy,
I was going on tour.
So My,
my dad had counsel and for his insurance policies to kick in for,
he needed to be alive to August and he'd done in the older end 11 he needed to
be a lot to August,
2012 because he had that type of policy.
He had just moved,
you know,
with me.
So we had a type pause.
He had to be alive for so long and he didn't make it and we didn't have one
working money to bear.
And so my,
I was like,
well,
I'll just go on my save.
And I was like,
well,
let me see what I can do on top of getting all of my brothers and sisters up
here to come to the funeral because we didn't have enough money to ship him home
and can't wait me hurt me on the phone telling my brother,
I say,
well wait till I get paid from this Gig and I'm gonna get y'all up here,
but I still gotta pay $9,000 a day if you don't know the fuck it's coming from,
because they only gave me 40,000 now care overheard me say that.
Went to the fucking wall and brought me like five g's back to bear my daddy.
I had not hit the stage that night.
Not one time.
And he was like,
here's your money,
you know,
go bare your daddy and come back.
And I was like,
you don't have to do this.
He's like,
I was like,
I can pay you back.
And he's like,
no,
you don't owe me nothing.
Don't know me from Dick out of war.
Wow.
And he helped me bare my daddy.
That's why when people say something like,
I was like,
fuck you.
I mean I was,
I was opening for somebody on a regular and they didn't even offer besides
flowers from a daddy.
I Dunno.
It's Katt Williams.
But my take on Katt Williams,
like when he does all this crazy shit is he's so fucking funny that you have to
be crazy to be that funny.
That's how I feel.
And they're intelligent.
You don't know you,
you see that character that he's done.
But if you talk to them smart as hell.
I believe that I had,
I had an interview that I listened to that changed the way I prepare for shows
and it was him.
He was talking about how he doesn't eat before shows.
And I,
I thought about it,
I was like,
you know what,
I've eaten before shows and not felt good.
Like I fell on,
weighed down by food.
My,
that's smart.
So I'm going to do that too.
So I give myself two hour window.
I will not eat with two hours before show the same window I give myself for like
working out.
It's smart,
smart thing that he said.
And um,
you know,
just talking about preparing,
he has music that he listens to special music right before
he got holes in his hands and his shoulders.
But he's so funny,
like all this different shit that happens to him.
Like he said,
he did his last special when he goes,
when you're standing next to shook night and you're the one getting arrested,
that's when you know you fucked up.
Very funny.
You know,
I don't like to hear people when they talk about,
you know,
people when they go through shit.
I was like,
cause you'd really don't know.
You really don't know the situation.
You just on the outside looking at me,
you fucking Internet thug.
I hate
she.
Well there's always going to be people that love to cast rocks to throw rocks at
people that are fucking,
you know what I'm
learning in this business,
what we were talking about before the podcast,
before Brian showed up,
people that are fucking with you,
let's say in a bunch of mean shit to you.
Somebody.
Oh they,
like I said,
come to the central release my internet virgin and somebody called me a black
can and I'm like user ignorant bitch.
Cop can't,
don't even ring bells in the hood.
You got to call me a bitch to get me riled up.
Can't it doesn't work in the hood.
No fucking cunt.
Nope.
Oh No.
Bitch might get you slapped but cut.
What the fuck gives a con?
I don't.
Fuck you.
Nothing,
Huh?
Yeah.
But you know I used to get on white checks.
Yes it does.
I heard a white boy called a white girl,
a con,
and this bitch broke out.
I was like,
what the fuck is a Chi?
What's wrong that all I had to go out with my friend.
Why is she crying?
He was like,
that's like calling you be a bitch or of the inward.
I was like,
holy fuck.
Keep crying.
Aye.
Ah,
you want me to help you whoop his ass?
I don't know why,
but kind of have so much of a power over white women,
but it just does.
It doesn't affect black woman bitch dude.
But you know it doesn't work on white women in England.
Everybody's caught over there in England and Ireland.
Everybody calls.
Everybody caught.
But he's a funny,
yeah,
he's a funny con isn't he?
And they'll ask you a question,
Ms Patches a funny contest and she,
Oh wow.
The only really say it about women though.
It's more like a man thing called men [inaudible].
Oh Wow.
It's like a,
almost a term of endearment.
Not over here for white women.
It has weird.
So we're not at work.
Why white women don't like cut and they don't like crow's feet.
And then the two things that pisses them off.
Crow's feet.
Yeah.
You mean like the lines near eyes?
Yeah,
in the makeup shop they are scared of Crow's feet.
Like a black man would appeal stone
assuming just filling them bitches and I'm like let it go girl is okay.
Let it go.
Well a lot of like blonde ladies especially,
they have that,
that weird skin that gets real brittle and thin.
Like thin skin does not age well.
Like one thing about black people and about dark skinned people,
Latinos especially they age better cause they have like a thicker,
like they have thicker skin,
you know Italian women,
they have thicker skin.
Like there's something about like white really white people.
They have that really thin skin.
I have a friend and he's my age and this motherfucker looks like he's 80 years
old and his kidneys and he's fucking blonde.
[inaudible] son,
a little bit of Sun but deep deep cracks like all over his face and his mouth.
I mean he looks really,
really old.
It's weird.
It's weird when you're around them,
you know?
It's like,
wow,
like he's only 47 years old and it looks like he's,
I dated this girl that had such thin skin that every time she would take a
shower you could see her whole entire circuit,
Tory system or certainly lawyers.
You know what I mean?
Like every single newborn white babies.
I used to be a medical system,
newborn white.
I didn't make this shit up.
That is true though.
Some white girls with really thin,
you could see their veins in their tits and it was something about the shower.
When she would get out,
you could actually see the blood just flowing around her body and it was,
I remember it was really concerned with boobs.
Yeah,
it really was.
It was a really concerned or a concentrated around them.
Boobs,
like a lot of veins going into the boobs and around the boobs.
For some reason it freaked me out,
but you still fuck.
I did made a tangent.
I used to be a medical assistant and
they will bring the white babies and that goes to white doctor's office and the
little babies would be,
you could just get them naked and they looked like she'd just run it through him
like some cut on and I was like,
holy fuck you mean it was really good when you get rid of this stick him because
you knew not to hit the vein.
So you know you give him but it he's really creepy.
Yeah.
Vans are creepy.
I have zero veins,
so whenever I have to give blood they have to like stick it in there and grind
around and try to find it.
And you should take some a 10 minutes slot.
It's Sunday.
You have zero vans,
you just have high body fat content.
All they had
about 10 pounds,
you're fucking Veno swim back to the top.
It's not the girl who was,
she was skinny,
right?
She's right.
Yeah.
Yup.
Can't see through my seat through body.
Yeah.
There's something about that white skin that's,
well that's also this guy that I know that a is,
it looks old.
He's already gotten skin cancer too,
not tan.
He just goes outdoors and doesn't put sunscreen on.
But he had a big chunk removed off of his head.
Jeremiah or walking just had a big chunk roommate from his back.
Right.
Another white guy again,
uh,
this huge chunk taken out of his back because he had,
he had like,
he just didn't do anything about it.
He had like this,
like a skin cancer,
like mole thing that started getting this changing colors and stuff.
I know quite a few people that have had skin cancer removed from their body,
you know,
malignant,
not malignant,
benign,
you know,
whatever it is.
Different kinds of like look,
cancerous moles.
Super Common.
My mom,
every couple of months and I have so many moles that I should get this checked
out.
I probably have it somewhere.
Well,
go get it checked out because that should become systemic and you're fucked.
I'm glad I'm black.
Yeah.
Black people.
Very rarely.
Well,
Bob Marley died of skin cancer.
Got It on his foot.
Yeah.
Bob Marley gets skin cancer.
I believe it was between his toes.
Bob Marley,
the manager,
uh,
was one of a manager.
It's supposedly killed him.
What Hendrix you're thinking of Hendrix?
Yeah.
The cancer that's killed.
It's genetically different.
The,
uh,
this is interesting.
The skin cancer that killed Bob Marley is genetically different in,
is not caused by the sun.
They've sequenced the DNA of a rare type of melanoma that caused,
uh,
Bob Marley's death.
That's really interesting.
Bob Marley's data's king counts.
Yep.
It's called acral melanomas.
The rare type of skin cancer.
Yeah.
And you couldn't get the toe off to say to me,
I don't,
I don't think he probably knew what was going on.
Diabetes and it's tall.
Yeah.
My Mama had,
my momma had a sore on her feet and on her foot for years and she tried to treat
it herself with fucking Vaseline and shit.
Yeah.
The diabetes thing,
it's like a circulatory thing.
It's like,
like,
uh,
it doesn't,
it,
she fell and she,
um,
she,
it was a little sore and she just wouldn't treat it and it just kept getting
bigger and bigger.
So when she finally went to the doctor,
they could have foot off.
They cut a leg off.
Ooh.
Yeah.
That happens.
A lot of people with diabetes.
My Mama and daddy had one lead.
God Damn Jesus Christ.
They probably didn't help him.
Bumping thump,
bump,
bump and nubs.
Now you know it's,
it's a weird thing that diabetes.
That's a scary one.
It doesn't sound like a disease until you fucking get sick from it.
Yeah,
I got diabetes.
It's almost like,
so I got crabs.
As long as I maintain them,
they won't kill me.
Oh,
that's what killed Patrice from diabetes.
Overweight people.
Very,
very similar.
Joe.
Setting that with nice chested ass talking about me and rent man didn't die.
Oh,
really?
Just means
does mean Joe.
Well,
that's why we're trying to get you a trainer.
I'm trying to make you not put too much coffee.
Sugar in your coffee.
Oh,
what am I supposed to do with it?
With what?
Your coffee?
Yes.
Just put the buttercream.
You're trying to get me the Stevia stuff was kind of stuff is pauses Divia.
Oh,
love it.
How are you?
Say that.
No,
that's fake.
It's plant extract.
Oh,
so it's not fake.
It's a plant extract.
Well,
you know everything.
You read
this,
people that are concerned about Stevia because they think that anything that's
artificial gives your body this glucose response and because it's not actually
sweet or it's not actually a sugar that your body gets confused,
but it's still better than diabetes,
whatever that fake my take is if you get cancer from Stevia,
something fucking wrong with you.
What?
Yeah,
that's what to just say something about Splenda.
SPLENDA is giving people counsel,
what do I do?
All those fucking crazy study one time they say,
oh,
we get a brace that we had a mammogram every year and that he's saying you can
go three years without worrying about your Ted is three years,
two or three years without getting a mammogram.
Now that doesn't seem right.
Yeah.
Some insurance on the pay like every two,
three years,
every year.
So there's,
the insurance company just doesn't want to pay for it.
Yeah,
of course.
[inaudible] sick,
you know,
how do they know your design?
See,
how do they know miss pat
somewhere looks on little white.
Do want to say some money.
Hey,
cut out the extra money for Teddy's.
Well,
what happened when you did get sick and you ain't got shit to suck?
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
So I take my titties in every year.
Good idea.
ASPARTAME is supposed to be really bad for you and that that shit was created
that was connected to what Donald Rumsfeld had something to do with that shit.
Get past aspartame is terrible that you've watched that today in a lot of
sweeteners,
a lot of diet sodas and shit.
I don't drink diet sodas has,
it's been drinking water.
I love chick fil late.
Eliminate
chick fillet is good.
The shit everywhere I go.
They Christian people that know how to make some good chicken.
And have you noticed they employees are never ugly.
A check flow.
They don't have other than employees,
they need him to Mcdonald's and churches and shit like that,
but never noticed her.
You sure?
Yes.
I'll never seen an ugly person that Chick-Filet.
They keep him in the back.
My son,
I love chick fil so much.
My 14 year old son got a job there.
So I can get a discount.
He worked one day.
I took him up there.
High Him.
That's hilarious.
He got a job.
How much of a discount is it really worth your son?
Hey,
when you go to three times a day,
well what the fuck you talking about?
This guy,
that grilled nuggets.
Oh,
they got nuggets.
So healthy does definitely healthy.
This is before I started exercising my son now.
Oh,
I see,
I see.
Yes.
Teach him how to work and be a little for the Discount Baltimore to let him know
that to get anything in this world,
you got to work forward including grilled nuggets.
Yes.
Mommy.
Just get mommy a discount.
Your first job is your mother favor.
Which restaurant?
Can you say that about yourself?
No.
Okay.
What that historical.
How do you,
how do your kids feel about you being on TV and being a famous comedian now?
Oh,
they love it.
And they live in our little white neighborhood.
They just love it.
Yeah.
That's got to make them proud.
You know,
I got two sets of keys and I,
and I say that I say this on stage,
I have a set of Medicaid keys and a set of blue cross blue sheer kids
and I have a great bit I'm working on about this but you know in my blue cross
blue shield kids live with me.
Like they,
my kids,
like my first kids grew up,
they got free lunch who was on welfare,
you know they was dad with my mood is struggling.
What Mommy and Daddy,
what you know now will,
we will off we okay.
We ain't well off.
We okay.
We ain't,
ain't no real struggles like it used to be with my first set of key.
So my,
my,
I call my blue cross blue shield kids.
Like they won't eat free lunch,
they won't eat free lunch and Essa.
They said as for poll people,
whoa.
Yeah,
they would not eat fucking free lunch.
And my daughter tell,
tell that I don't know if you've got any teenager,
well,
my motherfucking teenagers on loss of mine.
She told me last week and you know,
I don't really want to cuss with kids.
How could we live in the suburbs?
My daughter go time Mama.
Everybody come to school with a Starbucks cup.
I'm gonna need you to take me to Starbucks at six 40 so I can walk in school
with,
with a Starbucks cook.
I said,
motherfucker,
you don't go get you a cup now and put you some hot chocolate in that bitch when
you get on that bus.
It looked like you've been to Starbucks.
I ain't getting out of my goddamn bad to take,
you know Starbucks the fuck you think.
Damn,
I ain't that type of Mama to make you look cool.
So everybody in school wants to look cool by walking to school with Starbucks.
Cause yes,
all the white kids parents get up at they fucking bed in Midwest in the snow and
take day little white kids,
the Starbucks and Dunkin donuts so they can be cool.
Look what I got.
Who the fuck you,
you better get you a cup and reuse that bitch.
Act like you've been to Starbucks everyday.
I got plenty.
I hot chocolate in the kitchen.
Is it hot chocolate that these kids are getting or is it they get it.
They get the Mocha woke out.
They don't fast and shit.
You know the strawberry shit.
Super Sweet Mocha WOCA rapid frappaccino.
That's what my daughter,
I'm like you're Chino.
That's so much sugar.
She already fat shit.
Shit is so bad for you.
Yes.
And people drink that and they think the drinking coffee like you're drinking.
It's a shake.
If you go to my Starbucks in the morning or at two 30 after the schools and it's
just a line up the door.
Kids,
I'm telling you my daughter go up there to study.
What the fuck.
I ain't never studied it inside.
No restaurant.
People study at Starbucks.
Every time I go there it's filled with laptops.
It's ridiculous.
And you kids loud.
Well,
they set up,
people wear headphones,
they set it up where they have these nice tables,
coffee right there and it's free wifi daughter do study groups there and be
like,
pick me up from pick me up from our Starbucks.
I said,
look,
I'm not built like that.
Hunker up her from Starbucks.
I'm not a soccer mom,
not hauling.
You need other glass church.
You gotta walk your ass down the street and I meet you.
Oh yeah,
she'll be willing to do extra shit.
I don't want to do extra shit with your friends.
Okay.
Wow.
I don't want to just get your shit.
What do you mean by extra shit?
Pick them up for study group.
No,
motherfuckers ain't studying day.
You don't want to pick them up for study group because it's extra shit.
Yeah,
because I'm in the house probably in my underwear watching TV.
So you don't want to get out of your underwear to take your daughter.
My daughter's about to be 17 this month.
I don't tell her to learn how to drive.
She's like,
I don't want to learn how to drive because technically you responsible for me
till I'm 18 that's what we're taking care of.
You need those kind of arguments.
Yes.
Technically you're responsible.
That's the difference.
So I'm between the Blue Cross Blue Shield kids
a kit with a walk fucking home.
That's what I'm saying.
Exactly.
She you seeing the difference,
like the soft light for it?
Yeah.
A big difference.
Yes.
That's why you don't want to do that extra shit.
Tell you Joe,
my husband,
we fold.
My niece moved.
Then we will have to sit at the table.
My husband say you shouldn't allow the kids to vent personal.
I say fuck you.
If allowing them to vent.
Yes.
We get at the table and hear what they did at school today.
I dropped out of school.
I don't give a fuck what you did at school.
First of all,
I don't care what they did.
It's cool.
Really
not kindergarten,
they high schoolers.
I don't fucking know.
You don't want to talk to them.
I talk to everyday,
hey,
oh by,
I'm going in my room and get in the paper.
That's it.
You don't communicate.
You don't have to Joe my daughter go own it.
Own it.
Own about bullshit.
That's a good part of being a child.
No.
So,
so such got arrested for smoking weed and then it says such as on pill.
I don't know them mother fuckers.
I personally don't care.
I got real shit like I need to hit pay.
Oh my fucking computer to pay the bills I don't want to hit is bull shit you
going through?
You know,
so so such as having six.
My daughter is still a virgin,
thank God.
But I'm like if you were stuck and have something to talk about,
oh my God.
To her,
you'll talk to her about some shit.
No,
I don't want to just start fucking are you saying
talk to okay.
You know what?
That's so crazy.
My husband listened to that shit.
And your puppy such and such got arrested.
They on pills,
they getting high.
So I asked,
I said,
are you getting high no matter what I'm saying,
we'll shut the fuck up.
Well,
that's you talking to kids like that's part of raising kids.
You got to talk to them.
But
my husband,
he's very patient.
We have to set
your husband.
This is his first set of kids.
And your second set of keys?
Yes.
Wow.
So we get at a dinner table and my daughter want to just go own it.
Own it.
Do though.
The developing Newman dogs.
I was told,
shut the fuck up.
Shut the fuck up.
But you were also shut the fuck up.
But you know all the different cycles that you,
we talked about the broke.
I know,
but come on Joe.
Be Honest.
You really don't want to hit a bull shit,
but you do it because forsaking the parenthood.
No,
I don't respond.
I'm like,
you did key.
Shut the fuck up.
I don't want to hit his fucking high school shit.
Oh God.
God.
When you're talking to,
they're human beings.
That's what they're saying this to her.
But of course it's not a highschool shit to them.
It's their little lives and ain't no fucking life.
You get,
you get your mom and Dad,
your mom and dad pay for your food.
We pay for everything.
I mean you ain't,
all you're doing is living and making decent grades.
No,
they're alive.
They're experiencing life.
Yeah.
Okay.
What do you mean yell?
[inaudible]
wasn't raised like you're reacting to the way you were raised and you,
and you're expecting your kids to realize that you were,
you were raised in a harsh environment and your other kids lived a harsher life.
Then they're living and they should just shut the fuck up.
That's what you're saying.
I don't say that to them,
but that is what you're saying and it's ridiculous.
Shit.
High School Shit.
Just part of life.
No,
I'm just saying she ain't
shit.
I can't even relate to your offering getting high.
I don't know your fucking Furrion.
Well,
don't you?
I mean,
look,
if you're talking to her and she was five years old and she was telling you
these stories,
would you have the same reaction?
Right.
You'd be concerned at 16 you're like,
you're on your own.
I mean I listen,
but I don't want to eat.
I'm saying I don't want to hear the bullshit about who getting high,
who haven't.
Who this I should do is tell it all the people business.
But don't you want to talk to her about life?
Don't you want to like do talk code shirt?
So you do talk to her about the taste.
My second,
well,
my second set of kids,
my daughter is a test to her daddy.
Like,
I mean he's the world too,
so she don't really come to me.
We got that bond where we deal with each other,
but we really don't get along with the same people.
Like she's very fucking funny.
She very snappy.
She's very like,
okay.
I think my daughter thinks she's smarter than me.
Ain't gauge to her.
She is smarter than me because I didn't have no kids at 15 I didn't drop out of
school.
I didn't sell drugs.
You know,
she got a better life.
So in her head,
she's ways she no more shit than I do.
Let her tell it.
She smarter than me,
so I don't fuck with her.
You know,
I don't talk to her that much.
She chose,
she judges you by judges me past failures.
Here's your package.
She's talking about something like,
she was talking one day about history and if I don't know something,
I'm not ashamed.
I said,
I don't fucking know it.
That's what my Ms Troupe taught me.
You know?
If you don't know,
then tell the person you don't know.
The dumbest question is,
the question I asked is what I was taught.
So she was talking to someone about history and I was like,
what are you talking about?
She was like,
how dare you not know this?
I'm like,
ah bitch.
This is what I say to myself.
You know I got mad because I'm like,
if I knew it,
I wouldn't ask you.
She said,
how dare you not know.
How dare you not know it is.
What was it that you were sort of talking about history?
Somebody Hitler.
He is the first Jew friend that I really knew mean Jews.
The black people is just Jesus Christ.
We thought he was the only Jew in hallway.
So when you talked to her about Hitler and you don't understand what she was
talking to her father about history that day.
And then she said something and she was looked at me and say,
what you know about history?
And I said,
I know three motherfuck got killed in Chicago last night.
And she's like,
that's not history.
I said,
well I'm from,
and she didn't like it.
She got mad at her.
Well she kinda got mad.
So she thinks she's smarter.
So I asked her,
I said,
well she was,
I'm so much smarter than you.
I say,
Oh yeah,
yeah.
And I said,
no you're not.
You can't tear a cocaine into crack shit.
You told them that.
That's what you said to her.
Don't say that until the baby's 250 pounds,
250 pounds.
I say no baby.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
Should bring her next time I
come tell you Joe,
be no 15 year old is on this path.
Don't give a fuck if she's 20 there'll be no,
you wouldn't under 21 on this podcast ever.
No,
you will love her cause she know everything.
You know,
I do not want to hear,
you know what I tell you?
She's so fucking funny paint.
She'll be a comic.
I want her to beat.
They would say.
So she told me the other day,
like,
she actually,
she can write jokes like she'd give me if I'm working on some,
she's like,
what do you think about death?
So I'm in the car the other day and she said,
Mama,
you remember the time you want it.
I wanted you to go to the children's museum with me in Indianapolis.
And I was like,
yes,
I couldn't go because I had a geek.
And she said at that museum,
it was crazy.
I said,
what each hallway represented,
uh,
um,
a time in history.
Like they started like at the 50 sixties.
So you know,
the whole segregation shit,
you know,
white people skiing,
black people down the street.
And then she say they had this little black man hanging and in the head she
said,
did you know the KKK had albums?
And I was like,
what do you mean?
They're like,
yeah,
they made music and like keep the,
keep the race,
keep black people and you know,
all this bullshit,
whatever.
She was telling me then she said she got to the 70 hall,
there was the Lsd,
she said she got to the 80.
It was,
it was,
it was a term of rap music and um,
crack epidemic and you know,
teenage pregnancy and then you say you got to the last hall when they get on the
way out the door with Obama and she said all her white friends was like,
oh,
this is the worst hallway.
She was like,
oh,
did you not see that black man back then?
That's the worst holy cause Obama Republicans,
where we live at
Obama is the president of the kids was like,
that's the worst hallway out of all of them.
And my daughter's like,
did you not see that black man back there hanging and listen to the news that
she is so fucking funny,
Joe?
And I said,
you sure?
He was at a church in Brazil.
She said when she saw the KKK hang in the blood pressure.
It's like what got a church museum is
wow,
she's just fucking funny.
And she said,
she said so some of her white fruits like I'm so sorry,
I'm so sorry.
She's like,
don't be sorry for me.
That's your history.
That's how funny she is.
There's a lot of white people in the Midwest and I'm mad at Obama,
Huh?
Yeah.
They didn't blame the country's woes on the president.
Yes.
I don't,
you know,
I think,
I think with the whole Obama thing,
I think some of them just racist.
They want to have a black leader for sure.
So then the percent,
yeah.
You know,
I don't like using the race card cause I say everybody ain't racist.
I say some people are just assholes.
That's true too.
I truly believe that.
But there's a lot of
people that actually are enjoying the fact that Obama is the president.
So any,
any problem the world has,
they can blame on this black guy.
Listen to it is,
I had,
I have a dentist,
I had a dentist in Indianapolis.
Right.
So He,
Oh,
Miss Pat,
I'm so Christian and I believe in God.
Every time I was on probably as well dude,
white dude problems is only black patient maybe.
I know I was.
So I go in there cause he coached my son basket maker.
He coached my son's football team.
Joe.
I go in there,
oh you want to do a talk about Obama?
I hate him and I hate him.
So I'm saying to myself,
why am I'm going to keep letting you shoot me in my mouth and then you get
excited about Obama and get me to my pain meds and then kill me.
So I stopped going after because if you are a Christian you don't suppose to
hate.
Right.
But every time I come in that because I'm the only black patient you always want
to talk about Obama.
I said I don't give a fuck about what Obama doing.
I said he'd doing like everybody else fucking up.
They all spoke [inaudible] and you want to be technically they all fuckers any
and no matter which way you vote new,
never going to be happy.
No one has ever been a president where everybody thought they did a good job.
Thank you.
Bill Clinton got his dick.
So everybody had a problem with it.
Why?
You Know Hillary would through sucking Dick at the time.
Why are you going to knock a man for sucking Dick?
Getting his dick.
So if somebody come my miles and helped me,
so I'm going to agree.
You can help me Suck Dick.
Just don't fucking don't fuck him.
Suck his dick,
but don't fuck good girl.
What is the,
what is the rule there?
How's that work?
Please explain.
Just can't fuck.
Hey,
you can't fuck you.
You Know Dean,
you cross that line,
but as you do it,
you suck and it did you doing stuff I really get tired of doing.
I don't want,
that's why Hillary didn't get upset.
Okay Bitch,
you got to stick on.
Stuck up your ass,
Casey.
You know how you can go and get a massage and no one gets upset?
What'd you do after work today,
honey?
Oh,
I went and got a massage.
Nobody gets mad at you.
What if you like,
Hey,
can I get my dick sucked like,
yeah,
that would be beautiful.
What a beautiful world we live in.
Yeah.
And that's what I tell him.
I say,
nobody's good.
They're never going to please us.
I watched a document,
not a documentary,
but a speech to the day that Monica Lewinsky gave about about,
you know,
like being today about,
all the people that judged her and she's still talking about time,
but I'm like,
you're still talking about it today.
Like that's like,
like Jesus Christ.
Like I understand it was a big moment for the country because they put her in
her song.
She did.
Yeah.
Why don't be put on her socks.
She was talking about that in the speech,
but it was just something seemed like ridiculous that she's still talking about
it.
Do you think,
do you think being heard that she,
I got extra practice trying to be the best Dick sucker cause she knows in the
future,
every time she sucks at Dick,
that's going to be a thing.
You know,
like it has to be gagging and S.
I mean any the dates or if
she doesn't blow them,
they're going to be so upset for fucking president.
You won't blow me.
Everybody knows you so different.
That's the type of Dick you suck.
Presidential Dick.
Yeah,
but then you know that the guy knows that he's like below.
She wasn't around her mouth.
She would have had so many perps.
Huh?
If she didn't run her?
Yes.
I don't know what the fuck she tell for.
What did you tell for everybody?
Be fucking a president.
Oh,
fucking in that White House.
Everybody cheat.
That's what they do when they go on and fucking meetings.
They all go out and buy,
puts a scene in the bathroom and do what they do.
They don't feed them.
Whatever the fuck they do.
That was that Larry Craig guy that was gay sex though.
It was trying and don't give a fuck.
They go out and get one day life from me.
Why you running your mouth?
Why did you run your mind?
Did we really have to know that Bill Clinton fucked you?
Monica Lewinsky?
I woulda never fucking told.
Do you know she probably still could have been getting a chick on the side to
this day,
probably.
You don't tell on them type of people.
You tell if you fought right back.
You know,
you tell us
what you don't tell on a president.
You keep that the secret.
She,
she was telling her friend and her friend recorded the conversation or friend
threw her under the bus.
Skinny girl with the long nose.
Older lady who is angry.
Yeah.
Cool.
One getting no dick.
Yeah.
See that's why I say if you are a single woman,
you don't have bitches that got that.
Don't have a man cause all the,
those are the ones that's always trying to tell you about your relationship.
Oh,
you shouldn't take this shit bitch.
You ain't got no man shit.
You're lonely.
Yes,
that is true.
It's always the girls that have no men and have terrible relationships.
When they do have men,
they want to give their girlfriends some sort of an oh,
Debbie says,
oh fucking yes.
I have a friend like that.
Always want to tell me,
oh you shouldn't take this or you bitch other healthcare for over 20 years.
You don't shut your Medicaid.
We're as hell.
You ain't got no man.
I don't.
I tell people I don't fuck with single people because they'll have you thinking
their way and then you be up here.
A lonely old mulvack.
Well,
there's definitely some people that want people to break up because they're
single.
That's that as a fact.
Yeah,
definitely.
They won't what you got,
there's that too.
Yeah.
As soon as you leave and then you look up and she blowing him.
Well,
you told me not to set up that you told me not to give him hey.
No,
because this bitch was waiting in line to give him head.
I can't believe you're saying this what,
but you're right.
You don't tell nobody how good your man put it down.
You tell your girlfriend and her wheels get this.
I might need to go try that.
Really?
Yeah.
How common is that?
Very common among,
amongst women.
Do you think women covet their friends?
I didn't want it.
Well,
Huh?
You think women covet their friends?
Men like you know,
like a girls hanging around with you.
You're talking about your husband's.
I should get this one.
Each posting.
Yes.
Dealer from Ms Pat and you can steal shit from me.
I ain't doing shit with me,
so he ain't gonna do shit.
Yeah.
Y'All ass watching empire.
He got a job.
That's hilarious.
It's the ones who are broke.
Do you gotta keep an eye on right?
Well swung that delicious.
Delicious Broccoli.
This crowd.
I gotta get the fuck out of here.
It's been beautiful though.
Thank.
Thank you very much.
And you're,
so your episode of this is done happening,
happens next week.
Next week.
Next Thursday.
The 26 next Thursday,
26th on at 1230 is that one?
It's on at night and I'm taping.
Marin's showed this week.
Oh,
TV show TV show.
Beautiful.
Um,
people can get you a comedian,
miss pat on Twitter.
We need to fucking get that other miss pat.
I'm tired of spelling comedian wrong.
Okay.
I don't believe in that word,
by the way.
I don't believe in it.
It's like comedian.
No,
you're a fucking comic.
Your Goddamn standup comic.
Right.
Okay.
You don't need to be a female comedian.
Like what is that to say that it's categorized as you.
Yeah.
You know,
and I'll do no females top is really,
you're a fucking comic.
I'm a comic.
That's what I'm saying.
Right.
This we need to just miss pat m.
S.
P a.
T there's some person that has it and his fucking like one tweet.
It's bullshit.
They have no followers.
They're there.
Their tweets are blocked to,
can't even read their tweets.
Probably because people are bombing on them.
Give this pattern fucking name.
That's probably what's happening.
We're looking today and I didn't lose do that.
I will,
um,
Wednesday night where the a Wednesday nights sold out of the ice house.
Very few tickets left for Thursday night at the Ice House.
Um,
uh,
that's it this weekend.
Portland long sold out.
Tough Shit.
No chance.
Uh,
that's it.
there's some other dates that I put up on the books really recently.
Uh,
Dallas,
the majestic theater in Dallas that's coming up.
That is March 13th.
And uh,
and then there's a New York City one that's in April.
Just figure that shit out on your own.
Joe rogan.net.
Brian,
you got anything going on?
Uh,
Vancouver for 20 Vancouver for 20.
A good place to be for 20.
I'm at Marty's,
coming to joint March 26th through the 28th in Indianapolis.
Kapow and also I'm at the casino here.
Ah,
dammit.
I don't forget your name.
Yeah.
Out here.
Oh,
Chumash.
No comp Congo or some shit.
Congo.
Morongo Morango when's that?
Friday?
This Friday.
This week.
What does your website,
ah,
Ms. Peck,
comedy.com.
Ms Ms Pat,
There you go.
Come in and see you Wednesday.
All right,
beautiful.
Thank you my friend.
Thank you baby.
It's Pat,
ladies and gentlemen.
Goodnight everybody.
Yeah.